hey everyone this is manish from simply
learn and welcome to this video on email
marketing full course in this whole
course we will learn all about one of
the most trendy technologies today that
is email marketing we will begin this
full course video with what email
marketing is and how to set up email
marketing the benefits of it and a b
testing after this we look into the
different types of email campaigns and
how to engage new users with your emails
along with a hands-on demo using the
mailchimp tool we will then conclude
this video by discussing the essential
interview questions and answers to help
every individual crack an interview by
the end of this video i can assure you
that all your email marketing career
related queries would have been answered
for this training with me i have a
experienced email marketing specialist
rob and rahul together we will take you
through the various topics of email
marketing so let's start with an
exciting video on email marketing but
before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell icon to never
miss an update from simply learn
welcome everyone this is rob sanders
with simply learn and welcome today
we're going to talk about email
marketing tutorial so buckle up and
let's get started with email marketing
tutorial and so let's start out asking
the question why email marketing so
linda is the owner of an e-commerce
company and basically she isn't able to
take her leads the leads she's
collecting per day per month and convert
them into customers okay so customers
sign up but they don't buy her product
so she's left scratching her head
wondering what to do so how's she gonna
solve the problem of converting the lead
she gets into paying customers well look
no further than email market so you can
boost your sales funnel with the help of
email marketing so email marketing leads
to
email campaigns that lead to website
visits that can lead to product
purchasing email markings also in a it's
a very good way to generate a high
return on investment so
linda thinks this is too good to be true
your challenge made is a very efficient
way to generate a return on my
investment how expensive is email
marketing well email marketing is
neither expensive or time consuming
that's the beauty of email marketing and
so linda is now
very interested we've piqued her
interest she wants us to explain
email marketing to her in detail and
that's exactly what we're going to do
buckle up and let's get started and talk
about
what is email marketing so as i
mentioned to linda it's an efficient way
to convert leads into sales why because
we can send personalized emails to a
specific audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our products we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email marketing is very
effective at different stages in the
funnel okay so when i say funnel
customer life cycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer life cycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel
somebody's looking for something in need
of something and we can come to the
rescue in this case we're going to come
to the rescue with email and we can go
ahead and educate them on what their
need is and how we can collaborate with
them help them educate them solve their
problems with our product okay so that's
what email is going to do we're going to
communicate with them via email and
we're going to bring awareness to the
problem by solving the problem that's
what email is good for okay good for
generating awareness for our brand for
example we can share a newsletter with
our customers so we're running a
cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call to action to learn more so if
somebody's having some skin care issues
or not sure what products to buy you
know an email can cover that okay the
next
step in the customer life cycle is
consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking
they're a little further in the process
they're educated they know what they're
looking for so we can really hit them
with the right email we can send a
relevant email to promote our product
okay discover that perfect moisturizer
for your skin that perfect skin
moisturizer smooths hydrates and
contains spf 20. so we got the perfect
product for that person who's further
along the funnel and really is ready to
purchase that product so we can hit that
person up with the perfect messaging
talk about purchase the next step in the
life cycle well purchase well with
purchase we can send an email that
encourages that customer purchase our
product by offering them something okay
by giving an offer for example we can
give a discount discounts always tend to
work so that moisturizer that that
particular customer was considering
buying well they can move from
consideration to purchasing because
we're going to offer them a discount
they can't refuse okay so you know it
could beat for a specific date okay it
could be you know something that's going
to get them excited to buy the product
20 off of moisturizers pretty good deal
and especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products that
we're considering buying so getting
somebody that extra incentive to
purchase the product goes a long way via
email okay we want to take that next
step in the life cycle and nurture our
relationship with customers to ensure
they're loyal okay they've already
purchased how do we get them purchased
again that's retention we want to retain
our customers we want to get them back
to buy the same product or similar
products or completely different
products in our inventory so what do we
do we're going to send an email we're
going to send an email to active
customers okay we're going to give them
an offer just for them exclusively just
for them in this example we're gonna
give them a combo pack a facial kit at
just 39 and get a sunscreen worth ten
dollars for free so you can come up with
all sorts of different combinations on
offers key is the offer is exclusively
just for those who you want to target
and retain as customers because if you
just get somebody to purchase once it's
not going to work those people have
already taken the that step in the
relationship where they trust your
product they purchase your product now
you want to go ahead and treat that
customer special by giving them an
exclusive offer and then what we want to
do is advocacy
last step in that customer lifestyle we
want to convert that active customer
into brand advocates okay we want that
customer to talk about our brand for us
we want them to promote it and talk
about it with their friends so for
example
we want to send an email to those
customers to promote our products okay
so for example we could say hey the
sales of our products for this
particular day or for this month is
going to go to our favorite non-profit
could be educating poor children or
cleaning up plastic in the ocean or
saving animals we want to be able to
get them to speak on our behalf and say
look guys this is a really good company
you know they're offering me products
exclusively they've offered me discounts
in the past they have good products they
have a lot of different products and on
top of all that they help they help the
environment they help the needy okay
they care and so we can go ahead and
provide a call to action for these
customers that are loyal to our brand
and have them share the email with their
friends to spread the word on you know
what we're trying to accomplish for our
nonprofit or if anything just get them
to promote it maybe give them a discount
for every friend that they get to buy a
product okay it doesn't have to
necessarily be you know just sharing
with friends it can be that extra
incentive of giving them a discount if
they do share with friends and their
friends buy okay so this is the customer
life cycle and examples of different
emails that you can use at every step
along the way in the life cycle so let's
talk about email marketing set up so
email marketing setup we have a series
of steps that we need to go through in
order to get our email set up to go
ahead and send out to our target
audience and that first step is we want
to identify that target audience and
create segments so if you've taken some
of my and listened to some of my
webinars in the past about google
analytics about google ads we talk about
segmenting so it's about targeting a
specific audience that's what segmenting
is taking a piece of the whole so we
don't want to email all users on our
list all customers maybe we want to
target a specific segment okay so we
want to be able to identify that segment
who is that segment is it somebody who
or a group of people or
you know a partial list of our customers
who purchase a specific product i would
say so versus say our entire list of
customers because our entire list of
customers can purchase a number of
different products and so by targeting a
specific segment of our audience or our
customer base we can hone in on the
message so if they all have something in
common like they all bought that
moisturizer then we can go ahead and be
specific with our messaging then we want
to create campaigns and set an
appropriate call to action okay so what
is it that we want to say to these these
people this segment of users then once
you create that campaign and and set up
the messaging and call to action we want
to test the email before we actually
click send this is a very important step
test that email
before we send and then when we send the
campaigns immediately or we can schedule
a time so
my advice here is always schedule a time
you want to be able to figure out the
best time to send that email and then
once the email is sent whenever that is
you want to be able to analyze
performance and there are some key
metrics that you want to hone in on when
we talk about email marketing and some
of those are open rates click-through
rates okay response rate okay so we want
to be able to hone in on certain key
metrics when it comes to emails so
here's what we need to do create our
list add contacts to our list create our
campaign okay we want to select the list
choosey format
modify the template and then send the
email campaign so these are some basic
checklists that you want to do so let me
give you an example and go to mailchimp
so if i'm in mailchimp basically i'm
going to create a campaign okay
so
it's an email that i'm going to work
with and you can see with mailchimp i
have some some examples here regular
automated plain text or a b test i want
to do a regular email and i'm just going
to call it test and i'm going to click
begin
okay so we want to add our recipients
who are we going to add so we're going
to choose our audience okay
so we're just gonna choose a sample test
for now okay we can personalize the two
fields if we want okay so what do we
wanna do we wanna call people by their
first name their last name the first and
last name where we can customize it just
go with first name to keep it a little
bit personal okay then we have the
subject line here so it's all about
messaging right so whoever we're
targeting we want to be able to add a
message so we're just going to say and
and subject line is very key here so you
want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that segment
audience is we want to make sure that
the subject line is going to resonate
with with them so that they can open up
that email okay so uh we'll just say
have any good day we can make it better
just as an example something that's
going to be attention grabbing if you
will okay you can always tweak the
subject line in fact my advice is always
do a b testing on the subject line so
you can do two different subject lines
with one email to figure out which one
has better open rates and then with
mailchimp we can go ahead and design the
content of our email so we're going to
click design email okay we can select a
template we have some saved templates
already okay or we can go with a theme
so mailchimp has a lot of good offers
now there's a lot of different email
platforms out there i particularly like
mailchimp because of this very feature
they have a lot of good themes here um a
lot of different layouts that you can
use
okay so you know we're going to showcase
that product
okay and that's the template we're going
to use here so here we go we're going to
showcase our product we're going to add
that photo of our product here and we're
going to go ahead and put some nice
messaging in here with some nice call to
action we can put our logo up here for
branding again we can edit the content
here so based on that segmented list in
this example
for linda's company maybe she wants to
target those folks who bought her
moisturizer before her face moisturizer
and she wants to retarget them she wants
to go ahead and say hey you guys have
bought my product before check out this
new face moisturizer that we have to
offer so whatever the case is you want
to be able to plan that out ahead of
time you want to be able to plan out who
your audience is you want to plan out
your messaging and you want to go ahead
and set up the messaging based on that
audience so once you have the messaging
in place voila you're more or less ready
to go okay so
once you get the content all set up
you can schedule that campaign
okay and you can also add a social post
to your campaign so we can share that
information on social so email
integrates nicely with social media
so again that's that's pretty much what
you need to do here you need to really
think about who it is you want to target
choose those recipients
okay
customize it
and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines and then align that content with
that audience okay that's that's really
the checklist here so again we look at
this checklist creating our list who do
we want to send the email to so we added
our contacts to the list we set up the
campaign we selected the list we chose
the format we modified it with a good
subject line with some good messaging
and then we're going to schedule that
email campaign so that's the checklist
to go off okay so remember identify
target audience and create segments then
you create that campaign and in our case
we did set an appropriate call to action
you know get shopping basically we want
people to shop our new moisturizer key
thing here is before we send it out we
want to test that email
once everything looks good we're going
to i would advise schedule it but you
can always send the email when you're
ready i would schedule it at the
appropriate time and day okay so in this
case you don't want to send an email out
on a friday afternoon okay when people
are getting ready for the weekend you
certainly don't want to send an email
out over the weekend because you're not
going to have many people look and open
it and you probably don't want to send
the email out on a monday morning when
most people are getting into the office
from a long weekend and catching up on
emails so from my experience you know
tuesday wednesday depending on your time
zone i would always say you know late
morning early afternoon tends to be a
good time but that's why we have
performance that's why we can analyze
performance we want to be able to see
what the open rates are and the
click-through rates are so that we can
make adjustments for future emails so
let's talk about some of those metrics
so when you do send that email you know
we're going to look at that open run so
open rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who open an email
so okay so if we basically you know send
it to x amount of people
minus those emails that have bounced so
let's just say you know we sent it to
102 people okay for simplicity sake two
of those emails bounced okay so that
means that we've had a hundred net 100
emails that received the email and let's
just say 75 open the email okay we wrote
such a good subject line that they
opened it okay that's 75
that's a 75 percent open rate that's how
you measure open rate click through rate
okay so if they open it we hope that
they click on something and so
for all of those emails that were
delivered okay in this case a hundred
how many actually did click on our call
to action so let's just say
75 opened it out of the 100 that's a 75
open rate but of the 100 that actually
were delivered let's just say we had 25
that actually clicked on the call to
action and so that's 25
okay and so you want to be able to
measure not only who opens it but who
clicks on the call to action so that's
click-through rate for email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients who
clicked on a link of your email campaign
and actually completed the action so in
our example we're trying to get people
to click on the shopping call to action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails and of the 25 who actually
clicked we had 10 who actually took
action and purchase so 10 divided by 100
is 10
so you have open rate click-through rate
and response rate those are some key
metrics for email marketing okay the
first step is you got to get people to
open it that's where the subject line is
so important click-through rate that's
where the messaging and call to action
is so important we want to get people to
click on that call to action and then
the response rate we want them to buy so
those are our three key metrics related
to email marketing so let's take a look
at an example if we go back to our email
marketing platform mailchimp in this
example we're going to take a look at
some reports so most email marketing
platforms have reporting functionality
built in and so in this case what we
want to do is we want to be able to take
a look at the open rate click-through
rates of the emails that have been sent
out previously so here we could see our
april email coupon versus tools promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens and clicks so 14
open rate 1.4 click-through rate okay so
the march email that went out did a
little bit better 19 open two and a half
percent on the click-through rate
so here we could see how many people
actually were sent how many opened it
and how many clicks so this is a
mailchimp makes it very easy for us to
measure you know open and click rates
and then we can measure by revenue as
well based on the campaign so
that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in so most email marketing
platforms have open rate and click rate
already built into the functionality so
you can measure those two metrics
against any email so let's talk about
the benefits of email marketing so what
are some of the benefits well we've
already mentioned to linda that it's
cost effective it's time saving
real-time marketing
less intrusive builds credibility
increases visibility and brand awareness
and it's an easy way to track roi these
are all the benefits for email marketing
we're going to go talk about some of
these now so basically when we talk
about cost-effective you know some email
marketing platforms charge based on the
number of users who you send the email
to time saving well you saw how quick it
took me to set up that email campaign
the key is figuring out who you want to
send it to when we talk about real-time
marketing you know we're sending this
email out basically in real time trying
to meet our customers needs at the right
time it's less intrusive because we can
customize the emails okay we can as you
saw i can put first name in there to
make it more personal so when
something's more personal it's less
intrusive especially if it's a segment
that already knows your brand okay
builds credibility hey we gain
credibility when we offer exclusive
offers to repeat customers or you know
try and build advocacy by working with
non-profits okay it increases visibility
and brand awareness why because you know
we could send our email out to a large
group of people and that's a good way to
generate brand awareness and as you saw
we can easily measure you know not only
open rates click rates but roi so how
many people from that email went on and
purchased so we can measure that it's
very easy to measure email so let's move
into a b testing so a b testing is key
to email marketing okay so in email
marketing gaining high open rates and
click-through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay
in theory that's what's supposed to
happen we get more opens we get more
people to click we get more people to
click we're going to get more people to
purchase okay but it's not as easy as it
sounds so how do we make that possible
well we're going to do that via a b
testing i've already mentioned it when i
set up my example campaign in mailchimp
i stressed and stressed and stressed
that we need to have two subject lines
go out per email okay so before i stress
that again let me just reiterate what a
b testing is and a b testing is a method
to analyze which of the two email
campaign strategies most effective in
terms of high open rates and click rates
okay so in this case an a b testing you
can send out two emails you can send out
two subject lines you can send out two
call to actions you're just really what
you're doing is you're testing one
against the other that's what a b
testing is and so in my example i talked
about that subject line so for better
results a b testing can be done with the
subject line can also be done with the
email content so the subject line
impacts the open rate okay so i wrote a
subject line i don't even know how that
subject line is going to perform but if
i write a second subject line then i'll
be able to
basically give myself a better chance of
getting a better open rate because i'm
offering up two different subject lines
likewise for email content so the
subject line and email content are the
most important elements so we want to be
able to test them if they're interesting
intriguing
attention grabbing then it's gonna in
the case of subject lines a result in
open rates if the content itself is
interesting engaging a good offer a good
call to action then the click rates are
going to be increased so we want to be
able to serve up variations for our
audience so we want to consider an
example of an a b test where linda has
set up two variations of the email
campaign as an example so she's gonna
send two different subject lines to test
which one generates more open rates
because that's what subject line a b
testing is going to do one of them is
going to have a higher open rate
so in our example here linda sends
version a of the email to 50 of the
recipients with the subject line three
important strategies to increase your
open rate well version b which is sent
to the other 50
has the subject line three important
strategies to increase your open rate so
the only difference here is three and
three the number three spelled out well
because she sent out two different
subject lines she's going to now be able
to measure the success of that a b test
okay and it just so happens version a
has a higher open rate numbers always
tend to work in subject lines by the way
so linda sends version a of the email to
50
of the recipients okay eighty dollars
today but ninety dollars tomorrow and
version b to the remaining fifty percent
eighty dollars today ninety dollars
tomorrow and the only really succinct
difference here is using the word but
versus a comma and she sent that email
out and that email went out and the date
is coming in and she's going to measure
the success of that a b test well
version b has the higher open rate you
know we want to be short succinct and
stay away from those conjugations like
but okay it tends to have a negative
connotation so the shorter more direct
email or subject line 80 today 90
tomorrow not so passive more direct and
that tend to have the higher open rate
so you always want to test those subject
lines to generate high open rates
another example here version a again
gets 50 with the subject line uh-oh your
prescription is expiring version b your
prescription is expiring you folks
listen to this webinar right now i
wonder which one you think will perform
go ahead and put your comments right
below this video i'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so let's go ahead and measure the
success of the a b test okay so she sent
the email out two different subject
lines fifty percent got one subject line
the other fifty percent got the other
subject line and it just so happens
version a uh-oh your prescription is
expiring there's a little bit of a
you know personalization to that you
know for me your prescription is
expiring seems to be a little bit more
you know command-ish hey your com
prescription's expiring so we expect you
to purchase where you have the little uh
oh in front it's like hey you know i
think your prescription is expiring
maybe you should think about renewing it
okay i think that's how that's
interpreted at least that's how i
interpret it so i would probably go
ahead and click on that email with that
subject line so you could see subtle
differences in the subject lines make a
big difference in open rates so
in order to keep improving those open
rates you need to continue and not
continue should always do subject line
testing always because one subject line
is always going to have a better open
rate than the other so always do a b
testing when it comes to subject lines
and email content for that matter okay
so
we're always going to do continuous a b
testing so with continuous a b testing
we can test very various elements of the
email so you can always test the
sender's name the subject line the copy
the call to action the design the
imagery there's a lot of different
elements you can test with emails for
example center's name okay so
you want to personalize it as much as
you can okay you don't want to do a no
reply you want it to come from a human
being in this case sam okay at least
that's what i think let's see what the
test states no surprise version a has
the higher open rate if you customize
these things and personalize them then
it goes a long way sending an email from
a no reply is not a good best practice
let's talk about the subject line again
uh so we got webinar increase your email
open rates webinar increase your email
open rates so the webinar is dynamic on
version a okay so we're sending that out
and because it's dynamic that's going to
you know beat out the static webinar
increase your email open rates a lot
more elements we can test here so for
example the email
copy so learn some easy ways to increase
your email open rates join us on may 10
2019
7 p.m for an interactive discussion with
our experts well version b is more
personalized it's a same message but
we're actually addressing someone
specific in this case rachel so we can
measure the success of the a b test but
it's no surprise that anything that's
customized that comes from somebody a
name you know with a dynamic email
subject line is going to perform better
it's going to increase open rates and
it's going to increase click rates so we
can also test that call to action the
difference here is coloring save my seat
yellow versus save my c blue again go
ahead and play along here if you're
watching this go ahead and add a comment
and just see if you're right you think
it's blue or you think it's yellow on
the call to action color does go a long
way in email marketing so let's measure
the success of this a b test and it just
so happens yellow is going to perform
better why does yellow perform better
than blue what's more positive plus it
it kind of resonates a little bit
stronger and easier okay it stands out a
little bit better it's not as pastely
and dull as this shade of blue we're
using so you can see here we're testing
every bit of the elements of the email
anything from the from to the subject
line to the message to the call to
action and so at the end of the day you
know you want to be able to send out the
best email that's going to give you the
best results so we're going to send that
out the entirety of the email and we
could see version a looks a lot better
and why does version a look a lot better
in this example because look at the font
size is a little bit bigger version b
font size smaller harder to read that's
another thing you can test larger fonts
tend to do a little bit better now you
don't want to go overboard and have them
you know 48 points or 50 points and plus
you know 14 versus 12 goes a long way we
can continue testing we can test imagery
you can see here we have a hand aligned
with the call to action they just look
different that's all version a has one
type of hand version b has the other
type of hand aligned with the call to
action let's go ahead and send out that
test and see what works well version b
works why the hand stands out a little
bit more clear it doesn't blend in with
the call to action so you can see we're
testing different elements here and
we're always improving and adding to
what's working so we started out with
a no reply versus somebody's name then
we move to a subject line then we move
to personalization then we move to
you know call to action then we move to
an increased font meaning the design and
then we're adding imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test eventually you're going to get to a
point where you know the email is going
to be good and you're going to just
continue to test different options on it
to continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response from sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line gotta personalize the email to
rachel with larger font okay we got a
nice call to action that stands out with
a nice image to accompany that so we've
tested all these different elements this
is the best combination based on
everything we tested so when we get that
email to go this is what it's going to
look like in the future but guess what
we're not going to stop testing so we
can continue to test those subject lines
continue to test the messaging and
continue to test the email design
continue to test different call to
actions continue to test different
images you're never going to stop
testing with email marketing okay so
let's switch over to how to optimize the
subject line subject line is such a key
component to email marketing so as we
showed you in the last segment we tested
a subject line and we used a number the
number three versus three spelled out
just so happens that numbers tend to do
a little bit better they're shorter
easier to read and they resonate better
so including number in your subject line
you can include an emoji in your subject
line emails come a long way emojis
aren't just social media based you can
use emojis in subject lines i'd highly
recommend it you know i just sent out an
email last month with the subject line
about
you know spring showers bring may
flowers and guess what emoji i had in
that subject line a flower okay may
sound cheesy but it goes a long way so
according to experian subject lines with
emojis can increase open rates by 45
percent people resonate with emojis
especially if they're positive emojis
okay so we want to personalize those
subject lines for better open rate okay
when i say personalize don't be so stale
remember that subject line we tested
uh-oh just putting o in there made it
sound like we actually cared it was a
little bit personal it wasn't so
personal we weren't dressed in a
specific person but
one little word goes a long way in a
subject line because when people get
emails and they read emails and a lot of
people are inundated with emails the
subject line is what they're reading
first and just by personalizing it
adding a number
adding an emoji just making it positive
and easy to read they're likely to open
on email so personalized email messages
can improve click through rate and open
rates as well so you want to personalize
your email as much as you can whether
that be from the from field to putting
that person's name in the salutation so
personalized subject lines have been
found to increase open rates by up to 50
percent so don't come across as spammy
come across as you know who your
audience is and you're talking to them
and then you want to prefer title case
subject lines so title case subject
lines for example when i say title case
game of thrones is my favorite show
every initial letter in that title is
capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case game of thrones is my
favorite show it doesn't stand out as
much of course if you go with lower case
it definitely doesn't stand out it looks
illiterate and somebody's probably not
going to open it so you always go with
that title case the every initial letter
gets capitalized so how to optimize that
subject line well watch the length of
your subject line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters you want to keep it short
succinct and to the point but
personalized with an emoji with initial
caps on each word to make it stand out
but you have to do that within 17 17 and
24 characters so according to campaign
monitor the ideal length of a subject
line is up to 24 characters and they're
more likely to boost those email rates
okay so keep it short make it impactful
make it personalized like i mentioned
before if you get too long then it may
get cut off and it may not have the same
impact as something shorter so that's
why we always recommend keeping it up to
about 24 characters okay if you go over
by a couple characters not the end of
the world but try and stay within that
range develop a sense of urgency okay so
when we say sense of urgency we mean
sense of urgency meaning if that coupon
is going to expire you know you want to
let people know it's going to expire
that day or the next day or within a few
days okay so you can use things like
hurry up or limit offer or limited stock
or offer expires on okay so add a bit of
sense of urgency i mean sky's not
falling here but if that coupon's
expiring at the end of the week you
probably want to mention something to
the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up choose from over 300 in-demand
skills and get access to 1 000 plus
hours of video content for free visit
skillup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
so let's talk about optimizing your
email content so we focused a lot on
subject lines let's talk about the email
content itself so some ways to optimize
email content are we want to send the
content that is relevant to customer
expectations so content needs to match
that expectation we want to use bullet
points to make the content readable we
want to follow logical structure we want
to use compelling imagery and prefer
design emails with responsive designs
and what we mean by responsive design is
hey most people are going to be checking
that email on their mobile phone okay so
make sure when you design the email it's
also going to be good not just on
desktop but on tablet and mobile as well
and then of course just goes without
saying but avoid grammatical mistakes go
ahead and spell checked it and that's
why we put an emphasis on testing your
email before you actually send it and
when you actually send an email test
email
don't send it to yourself send it to
colleagues you know send it to another
group a fresh set of eyes a fresh set of
eyes like it's going to be able to pick
out that misspelled word that you
overlooked so i can't stress the sending
of the test email because it's going to
be able to
you know in a way ensure that you're
doing everything on this list in
addition to grammatical mistakes you
know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work may be
looking at that email on their mobile
phone and if it doesn't look good to
them they're going to let you know some
other ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the a
b testing you always want to personalize
it question is hey do i use first name
do i use first and last name well guess
what you can test that but you want to
personalize it okay you want to choose
the right fonts and colors for your
email so
when we were going through some examples
on testing you know i always tend to go
a little bit larger on the font but you
can play around with it i don't think
you should probably use white lettering
on a black background that just is not
very good or best practice but go ahead
and try it if you want okay you can
always play around and test these but
you want to choose something that's
really going to resonate with the
recipient of the email okay you want to
build a rapport with customers by
sharing insights they value for example
the beginning of this webinar we talked
about advocacy we talked about you know
sharing with them some of the nonprofits
that we work with as a company okay if
we have a you know cosmetics company and
we have different products like
moisturizers and facial creams we may
want to state that hey we don't use any
animals in the testing of these products
you know we're pro animal we're not you
know we're not going to use animals in
the testing of our products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to go
ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights and
use recipient names and you always want
to personalize it then add a clear call
to action at the end you always want to
have that call to action regardless of
what the email is hey could be just a
simple read more or hey donate it
doesn't have to always be so hardcore in
terms of hey purchase our product that
could be a turn off especially if you're
sending emails out once a week to your
customer base they're constantly
hammering them with buy now buy now buy
now they're going to get turned off so
you want to mix up the call to actions
and that goes back to the very first
step and what kind of email are you
going to send out and who are you going
to send it to so you have to align those
two it's somebody who doesn't even know
who your brand is you're not going to
put a call to action of buy now you're
probably going to say hey check us out
we have some cool stuff for you okay
let's talk about automating emails email
automation so triggered emails are sent
to customers based on an event date or
user behavior okay so when we say an
event could be a special occasion like
mother's day okay it could be a date
like a birthday or anniversary or
specific day of the week could also be
based on user behavior
you know a good example of user behavior
are those who abandon the car you can
trigger an email in fact mailchimp has
remarketing functionality so with
mailchimp hey if somebody abandons our
car we can have an email triggered and
we could send an email a nice email that
says hey we noticed you didn't finish
purchasing our product and i'm not sure
what happened but hey here's another 10
off or you can always just make product
recommendations as well but you want to
react to user behavior and use emails to
your advantage for that so you want to
take be cognizant of different occasions
you want to be cognizant of special
events holidays etc and user behavior so
these types of emails can be automated
because you know when they might happen
or that they are probably going to
happen so autoresponder emails are sent
at frequent intervals based on the
behavior of subscribers so for example
if somebody purchases something then
you're going to get an email that
probably says hey thank you for your
purchase another email that says hey
your products on its way and then
another email that says hey your package
your product has been delivered so
that's an example of an automated email
that goes out if somebody purchases your
product you probably want to thank them
for that then you probably want to let
them know that hey it's on its way here
you could track it and then again you
want to confirm that it's been delivered
but thank them again so that's an
example of an automated email that goes
out okay let's talk about types of email
campaigns so we have different types of
email campaigns and the first is a
newsletter so with email newsletters
subscribers are connected and informed
about product updates so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a product they
buy it could be a product they subscribe
to like software okay you always want to
be able to send out that newsletter to
let them know what's going on with your
product are there upcoming product
updates ahead is there one that just
happened is there a webinar that
discusses the new product update so
that's what the newsletter is going to
do inform the end user about the update
so how to optimize okay so you stack
your email content create a compelling
header share different variety of useful
content like videos articles etc with
those recipients and then follow a
consistent schedule so that's how you
handle a newsletter you should always
create a compelling header but if you're
going to send a newsletter make sure you
support it with some good information
like a video that they can go watch or
an article that will follow up on what
you put in the email or promoting that
webinar that's going to talk about that
product update so example here is a
newsletter that gets sent out and here
you can see
it talks about business process it's got
some nice imagery in there okay call to
action it's got a little bit of
everything in this email template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talk about
stacking you can see at the top it's got
work with the industry best subscribe
now okay they validate that with 25
years of top notch service then they
talk about hiring the best talent and
you got the next bit of content below
that so that's stacked email content
okay that's going to be supported by
compelling header and then they're going
to share a variety of different content
in there like there could be clicks in
there to video videos and articles
moving on from newsletters to
promotional emails so we want to be able
to drive revenue by sending special
offers through promotional email okay so
how do we optimize a promotional email
well we want to personalize the campaign
okay promotional we want to definitely
personalize it include time sensitive
offers we want to get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title and the
subject line okay you can send offer
emails on holidays if it's mother's day
hey send it a couple days before or even
send it on if it's personalized then you
can say hey
so and so we know you're a mother here
take 20 off i mean that kind of
personalized email with an offer goes a
long way here you an example from toms
limited time extra 20 off all styles
they include the code in there okay
again you can see the the sensitivity
and the sense of urgency with the
limited time another email campaign type
and personally one of my favorites is
abandoned cart so abandoned card emails
i like working with the banner card
emails because you know we want people
to purchase and as much as you try on
your email marketing campaign to drive
traffic to the website and as hard as
the website works to get people to
convert through the shopping cart it's
never going to be a hundred percent and
so abandoned cart emails give us that
extra incentive to get that person back
to the shopping cart to purchase okay so
these emails are shared with customers
who have added product to their cart but
didn't finish through the checkout
process in other words they didn't
purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it gives
us another opportunity to reach out to
that person who just is almost there but
not quite ready to finish the purchase
so what are we going to do we're going
to send out an email for those that
abandon their car and we're going to use
a simple abandoned cart email template
okay you want to be simple here you
don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish purchasing the products and we
want to definitely personalize it okay
we want to send a series of email
reminders okay in your email reminder
add a product image so as customized as
it can be it could be even the product
image of what they've abandoned and
that's the best practice so
if it's that facial moisturizer that
linda is trying to promote and she can't
quite get enough people to finish
purchasing the product they're they're
banning the cart well she can certainly
send out the abandoned cart email okay
so for example
you want to personalize it hey you
forgot to complete your order you left
something in your car can we help
email too hi there so and so items in
your shopping cart are selling out
quickly it's a gentle reminder okay so
come across a little bit different here
okay email three hey so-and-so twenty
percent off on your car valid until so
and so offer on your favorite product so
the first email that went out and the
series of emails hey you forgot
something hey is there anything we can
do to help you complete the product
purchase email too is just that gentle
reminder hey you're selling out quickly
you might want to purchase that product
and the email three is to really help
them along by saying hey here's 20 off
valid until so and so so just a small
series of emails that go out try and get
somebody back into the shopping cart
okay let's talk about re-engagement
campaign so in a re-engagement campaign
it's a series of emails sent to inactive
email subscribers so what it does is it
boosts engagement and helps to maintain
a high inbox placement ratio inbox
placement ratio so we want to be able to
make sure that we're getting people back
on our subscriber list so how we gonna
optimize for something like this this is
you know these are difficult type of
email campaigns we're trying to
re-engage with people who are inactive
so we want gamification to re-engage
subscribers or we want to prefer subject
lines like hey we've been missing you or
did we do something wrong okay we can
run a poll or competition to re-engage
with our subscribers so for example hey
we'd hate to miss your birthday go ahead
and update your account this is a
starbucks email so we'd hate to miss
your birthday so it's that you know
message of missing you you can always
soften or sweeten the deal with an offer
as well so that brings us to how to
engage with new subscribers so we just
talked about re-engaging with inactive
we want to talk about engaging with new
subscribers so how to engage with new
subscribers well thank your subscribers
for joining
create clear and compelling subject
lines that is a must regardless of what
type of email you send out you always
want to send out a compelling subject
line okay we noticed the good examples
within 17 to 24 characters know the
ideal time to message okay again sending
it on the weekends not gonna work okay
sending it out during the weekday you
know in the morning mid-morning you know
sometimes in the afternoon works really
depends on who your audience is but
weekends probably aren't going to work
okay avoid the no reply center name
again
personalize it you're either sam or rob
or so and so sally you know let them
know that the email's coming from a real
person okay because if it doesn't come
from a person most people aren't going
to respond okay we want to let our
subscribers know the privacy policy so
we want to let them know that we abide
by a privacy policy okay that's you know
getting you straight with people who are
new they don't know your brand they
don't know your privacy policy they
don't want to get spammed in other words
so putting that out there makes you more
transparent and trustworthy okay and
again
personalization always personalized if
it's new if it's inactive repeat
customers loyal customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous and
always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs okay work with
something that's going to be eye catchy
and then most important most important
is include an unsubscribe link i can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email and not have the unsubscribe link
there that makes me want to
unsubscribe
even if it was a good email i still look
for that because maybe they're good
company but they're spamming me they're
sending me too many emails so maybe i
want to unsubscribe or change my
subscription so you always want to
include that unsubscribe link in fact in
the united states it's actually law so
there is regulation about that around
that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy if anything so it bodes well
okay of course you don't want people to
unsubscribe but you don't want them to
get annoyed either okay let's talk about
email marketing tools so we talked about
mailchimp so there are plenty of email
marketing platforms out there i use
mailchimp i've used a few in the past
like marketo i've used zoho vertical
response
so there are a lot of different tools
out there here some of them again
mailchimp marketo marketo is a marketing
automation tool or system and marketo is
good for sending those automated emails
hubspot convertkit send in blue aweber i
mean these are just some of the many
that are out there okay so let's show a
demo again of an email marketing
campaign so let's show an example of a
newsletter that
one of my clients had sent out and so
this is paul ekman group paul ekman dr
ekman inspired the tv show lie to me so
well known in the industry of micro
expressions he's the aforementioned
expert in micro expressions and he sends
out email marketing campaigns and he
sends out a monthly newsletter so this
is a a newsletter was sent out in
november 2018. and if we look at it you
can see here okay it's stacked content
nice imagery okay respectful
disagreements how to deal with
disagreements this holiday season so
really relevant personalized because and
timely because it was set in november
during the holiday season so got some
nice imagery there okay we got content
in here and then right below that on the
stack content what do we have final hour
24 hours 25
off so that sense of urgency built in to
the email then here you go you have some
other content in there based on the face
of contempt okay just an example of a
micro expression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action learn how to use microexpressions
to your advantage so call to action here
then we have some more information here
with the learn more so a newsletter that
went out basically really a blog post
built into the email with some nice
content reminding folks hey they have 24
hours got some other useful information
in the email so this email went out very
timely 98 000 okay see subject line here
controversy respectful disagreements and
thanksgiving okay could the subject line
be a little bit shorter yes possibly but
if we look at the open rate 15
16 open rate okay industry average in
education and training is 18 okay so
they're close to the industry average on
the click rate you know 1.6 percent on
the click rate industry average 2.1 so
we can see what the top links were
clicked okay so they have a lot of links
and and mailchimp will help you measure
what links were clicked the most who
subscribed what subscriber with the most
opens we can see opens by country but
that's an example of a newsletter for
this particular company okay stacked
content okay sense of urgency okay you
can see the subject line timely
newsletter so this is a
a good i think a good example of an
email for the time of year okay so let's
go over the checklist again for email
marketing so good reminders on the
checklist this is a checklist you want
to make sure
all boxes are checked you want to create
interesting subject lines as they boost
your open rates direct correlation with
open rates is subject line okay you want
to keep your content relevant and
consistent with your brand you want to
check the sender name okay so you want
to make sure not only is it personalized
but the name aligns with the email
address okay should always personalize
always personalize the subject line and
the email copy text meaning you know
don't just say hello say hello to sally
p
rob
michael etc always include an
unsubscribe link in emails and give
people the option to unsubscribe okay
you can always re-engage them another
way or later on but you don't want to
irk any one of your potential customers
use a b testing we talked about a b
testing the webinar there's lots of
different elements we can test from
subject line to content to font to call
to action to imagery to subject line etc
there's no shortage of elements in an
email you can test you want to use
welcome emails to build good customer
relationships so when somebody signs up
for a newsletter send out a welcome news
email to them hey welcome thank you for
signing up you should always segment
your list based on user behavior so you
have a group of people who purchase
product a customize your email for
product a but you know you can mention
product b and c in there but know who
your audience is so you can talk to your
audience and you can always ask your
subscribers to update their preferences
as well because you want to make sure
you're sending out emails to the right
person right address okay this is a
short checklist now we can expand upon
this but these are some of the most of
the key items when it comes to email
marketing some other items on the
checklist include features such as
countdown timers and live polls okay
make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency don't be sending
emails three or four times a week once a
week is probably as much as you want to
go depending on what it is if somebody
purchases something then you probably
want to send an email thanking them for
the purchase another one letting another
product has been shipped and another one
with thank you the product has been
received reward those subscribers send
out exclusive offers okay make sure your
emails are optimized for mobile that
means send out test emails and check it
on different devices okay create a
schedule okay you can automate these
emails so create a schedule that makes
the most sense have a footer and header
in the email and in that footer and
header is going to be some information
okay just like i showed you with the
micro expressions there was a footer and
header avoid spam filters okay how do
you avoid spam filters well apply best
practices and don't have spammy subject
lines have an actual name associated
with the reply to email and and split up
your list as well when you send out one
email to 150 000 people it could
probably get caught up in some spam so
segment out your audiences keep your
audience list short so that your
messaging can be
specific to the audience that's going to
help avoid spam and then of course you
always want to measure and analyze
results so remember a lot of these email
marketing platforms have the results
built in especially open rates and click
rates we're going to talk about
mailchimp so we're going to go through
the features and benefits of using
mailchimp azure email content platform
so buckle up and let's get started with
mailchimp so the first thing you need to
do is sign up for an account with
mailchimp and that's simply just
providing an email address an id and a
password and i recommend when you
actually sign up for an account you sign
up with the free plan first and let's
take a look at what the feature plan
features are for mailchimp so i'm
recommending the free plan but when you
actually sign up you have the option to
actually pay for a plan so you have the
essential the standard the premium or
the free and so i recommend you go with
the free version first it's like buying
a car you want to test drive it out see
if you like it see if you like the
features and benefits and you can see
here that with the free plan you get a
lot of features and benefits so you get
all the basics for businesses that are
just getting started so if you're just
getting started with email marketing i
would recommend the free plan here
because you have a 2000 contact maximum
so that means you can send out an email
to your 2000 recipients free of charge
so not a bad deal for businesses who are
starting out i mean if you are prepared
you've used mailchimp before then go
ahead and sign up for one of the paid
versions each version has a different
set of standards a different set of
features and benefits from the essential
all the way up to the premium where
you're gonna get you know advanced
features um and more customization but
that's 299 dollars a month so if you're
not prepared to pay that amount then my
recommendation start with that free plan
now when you actually do set up your
account you're just gonna again provide
a id email address and password you're
gonna go through a couple of steps and
one of these steps that i would
recommend you do right away is connect
your facebook and twitter accounts so if
you already have a facebook and twitter
account very simple all you're doing is
authorizing mailchimp to connect to the
account and the reason for that is when
you actually connect your twitter
facebook account you'll be able to then
you know share content on those
platforms and mailchimp will do that for
you automatically okay so here you're
just asking it to
more or less interact with the platform
social platform and i recommended doing
that as you're going through the setup
process very simple to do if you're
already logged into your twitter
facebook account all you need to do is
click on the plus button as you go
through the setup wizard and authorize
mailchimp to access your twitter or
facebook account here you can see what
mailchimp's going to be able to do
they're going to be able to read tweets
from your timeline post tweets for you
on your behalf if you want them to if
you want them to you're going to allow
mailchimp to secrete and manage your
advertising data including the campaigns
and audiences and the reason for this is
you may
you know want to integrate your email
marketing efforts with your social media
efforts and the great thing about
mailchimp is hey look if you want to
post content on these platforms you'll
be able to if you want to leverage other
benefits from facebook and twitter and
integrate them with mailchimp you'll be
able to so having these two platforms in
the case of facebook and twitter talk to
mailchimp is a positive because then
you'll be able to do a little bit more
get your message out there a little bit
more so i highly recommend you take this
as a necessary step when you're going
through the setup now it's optional you
don't have to but i recommend it now
when you're actually setting up your
account you're going to be asked to
you know design a template okay so you
could pick a template just by default
you could pick one just to get the
account going but you can always go back
and add or change out the template so
here you can see i'm in the setup wizard
but i arbitrarily just chose a template
i can go back and choose some of the
templates that are available to me now
again you can create your own template
if you want to okay so you just click
create template and
you'll be you know asked to choose kind
of a you know template that you can
pretty much change and customize so if
you're thinking about sending out an
email with an announcement then that's
the type of template you want to choose
and so here now you can see we have a
logo we can change the announcement here
we can add photos etc so if i want to
add my logo i'm just going to go up to
this top portion here click the little
pencil icon that allows me to edit here
you can see it's the default logo i
don't really have a logo so i can say
replace it i can also link to it and
here you can see in the content studio
of mailchimp i don't have any images to
choose from so i'm going to go ahead and
upload one and i'm going to go ahead and
upload my logo that i've had on my
desktop okay so it's going to upload and
now i can select that and insert it so
now i have my logo as part of my
template here and
you can also see you can add some
styling here to this hot header part so
i can add a nice border around that okay
so i can align its center i can go edge
to edge okay so i can customize the
image in this particular template here
so i'm just going to click save and
close now i'm ready to move on to the
next part which is just click on edit i
want to make an announcement okay share
your big news okay we're
having a launch party okay so here you
can see again just in this template this
quote unquote announcement template i'm
able to just make changes to each
section now i'm in the section of the
announcement part where i can now
customize the text and you can see i can
you know bold it you know i can choose a
different font go ariel i can choose the
size
you can make it smaller larger pretty
easy to use i could again style it with
different color and so i can make
multiple columns here if i want to so
there's a lot you can do just in this
one section as well so let's go ahead
and just do one more thing here let's
maybe call it or something i mean you
can see i can add a link let's go ahead
and make it blue that's the background
so i want to change the background so
i'm just going to click ctrl z i'll
change the color of the font itself
there you go very simple and easy to use
now i can add photos here if i want to
so let's go ahead and edit this bottom
part here so i'm going to click again
the edit icon okay so here you can see i
have three images in the template i'm
gonna go ahead and add to that so here i
can go ahead and upload some files so i
have some files waiting for me on my
desktop i'm just gonna go ahead and add
them and upload them to the content
studio and
now that i've uploaded them i can select
one of them to insert okay now i'm going
to go here insert the second one and now
i'm going to grab the third one and
insert that in its place here you can
see now i can go ahead and you know
style each one of these if i want to
okay i can add a border again okay i can
go ahead and do rounded corners okay
settings you can see how i can set it up
this so they're all vertical i can do
this so i have a lot of flexibility
in
what i add to these particular you know
templates okay this is again just the
announcement template and so now i'm
going to click save and close and
here you can see i can add some other
things to it if i wanted to i could play
around with the design and header and
once i'm done really if i'm happy with
my email i can just close it out and i'm
done so what i can do now is when you're
done with this template you can just
preview and test it so i could send a
test email or enter preview mode so if i
enter preview mode this is what the
template i chose is going to look like
if i happen to send it out okay this is
what it looks like on desktop this is
what it looks like a mobile and if i go
inbox preview i'll need to upgrade my
account because i'm on the free version
so but i can certainly see what it looks
like on mobile on desktop so i'm just
going to click out of that and this is a
template and so i can go back and edit
this anytime i want so when i'm done i'm
just going to go ahead and click the
mailchimp icon in the upper left it's
going to ask me to name my template so
i'm going to name this the announcement
template i'm going to click save and now
it's in my templates so i'm free to use
this template anytime i'm ready to send
an email okay and again i can you saw
how easy it was to make a change in the
template itself so when i'm ready to use
the template i can just go ahead and
grab it okay and again i can go ahead
and style it and design it any way i
want so you have different sections of
the page that you can style and here you
got you know mobile style designs if you
wanted to now if you wanted to in the
template if i want to like duplicate the
whole blog i can duplicate that whole
block and you can see it just copied it
or i can just get rid of it it's a very
easy to use
wysiwyg if you will or interface it
allows you mailchimp allows from some
easy you know functionality easy
features to go ahead and manipulate and
change to your liking okay so again i'm
working with a template here so anytime
i'm ready to use that template for an
email i can go in and start using it
okay and if i go to templates again i'm
gonna find my template here i can always
edit it i can always share it i can
always preview it i can replicate it and
that's the important thing so if i
wrapperclade it i'm basically creating a
copy of it okay so i just created a copy
so now if i wanted to create a or change
the copy of it i can do that so if i
don't like this whole block i can just
delete it and now that i'm done i can
rename this i'm just going to say
announcement template v2 so now it's
been renamed and now i have two
templates just simply by choosing one
and replicating it so again if i go back
to templates here here i go i have my
two templates and i can store these in a
folder so i'm going to add a folder i'm
going to call it announcements and i'm
going to add the folder and that's it so
now i can store these in the folder so
you can organize all your templates in
different folders if you want to so i'm
going to take these two templates here
move them to my announcements folder and
there you go they're in the
announcements folder so if you're going
to create multiple templates then i
would recommend you go ahead and
organize it create folders you know and
set up as many folders as you want and
need because you're going to probably
have different templates for different
occasions depends on what type of email
you're sending out so i just chose
arbitrarily an announcement type email
so now if i go back to create templates
okay you can see again let's go through
some of these others again i just chose
make an announcement you can tell a
story follow-up educate
you got all sorts of different templates
that you could choose all sorts and here
you got some themes so you can even go
with a theme if you wanted to so for
example if you're selling products let's
just say you have a boutique store let's
just choose this boutique template if i
choose this here is my themed template
and so now
just like the other template i i was
working in i can go ahead and edit this
here you can see at the top i got the
middle section you know i got all these
different sections that i can now go
ahead and edit so just about really it's
about choosing the theme template that
works best for you and feel free to
you know try these different templates
out and see what works best for you so
here you can add in certain things like
you know social share so if i just drag
and drop i can add in a social share or
image card so a lot of these themes are
very flexible in what you can do in
terms of the design in terms of the
content so again if you go back and i'm
going to cancel and not save this temp
well let's save it we'll call it
boutique we may use it again in the
future so i'm going to go ahead and
click save and now it's a template it's
going to be located in templates and
again if you always want to access
templates just go to templates you'll
see the templates that you already have
created and edited so you can edit them
always just by clicking the edit button
now that's again if you want to create a
new template just create click on the
create new template call to action again
you got themes you've got layouts or you
can even create your own from scratch
you can import another template that you
created in another email marketing
platform or you could do simply just do
everything from scratch and html so you
have three different options here
layouts themes and creating a template
on your own okay and that's either by
importing or by creating it from scratch
okay my recommendation i like some of
the layouts that mailchimp has you can
see a lot of flexibility here and when
you actually choose one again you're in
full control of how to
design and message it so you're in full
control of that so if you just want it
again tell a story i'm going to select
this template here okay now i'm on the
free version so keep in mind with the
free version i don't have access to all
the templates so here i get to upgrade
to use this one but for example if i
don't see the message upgrade to use
then i'm free to grab it so you can see
the one column i'm free to use so i'm
just going to select that and now i have
this template available to me so again
i'm free to edit this one as i see fit i
mean i can go ahead and again drop in
any one of these elements that are
available to me here i'm going to drop
in my social block okay so here you can
see i can now customize my social block
if i want to add in another platform i
can do that social media platform click
save and close so you can see they're
very customizable all of these themes
and layouts are very customizable and
again when you're done it's just a
matter of you can preview it or test it
you can enter preview mode or you can
send yourself a test email okay so if
you send yourself a test email you can
actually see how it looks when it comes
in so let's go ahead and do that here so
i'm just going to send myself a test
email and the email has been sent so
let's go check our inbox so here is the
email that
i just created from the theme you can
see here all i did simply when i edited
i just dropped in my social block in
here so this is what the email looks
like and the great thing about mailchimp
is they have an option that you can view
the email in a browser if you can't or
you don't want to look at it in your in
this case i'm looking at gmail so you
can always or recipients can always view
the email in a browser versus the email
client that they're using in specific
now when it comes to completing your
profile on mailchimp you're going to
need an audience to send these emails to
and so when you click on audience here
if you don't have an audience already
imported into mailchimp you're going to
be asked to import so you can see i
already have one contact that contacts
me because i added my email address on
that test email so mailchimp is smart
enough to say okay we don't have this
email address and our contact list so
we're going to add them so here we could
see we can manage our audience so we can
add subscribers we can import contacts
we can have sign up forms and we can
manage our contacts so if we import our
contacts if i click on import here i'm
going to be asked to import either from
a csv or copy and paste or i can just go
ahead and integrate it so if i choose
for example
any one of these then it's going to pull
in the context i have there and so
it's up to you how you import your
contacts now the whole point of contacts
is you want to probably or really not
probably it's a best practice to
actually create different lists so that
you can use different audience lists
with different emails and so here you
can see i have one email address i can
again import contacts or i can add them
individually so i can add subscribers
here okay that's another option that's
the slower option my recommendation be
import them but when you import make
sure you you're importing lists that
have some commonality so you can manage
those lists so if you have one list that
are say
you know clients who have never
purchased then you want to create a list
for them if you have clients who have
purchased separate those out okay so
that's the way i would go about it now
if you're trying to build a list
mailchimp has what they call signup
forms so you have different forms that
you can embed and or have as a pop-up
and when people add their email address
to that form then it's automatically
going to get added to your mailchimp
account so that's a great feature in
mailchimp that allows you to you know
build out your audience just by using
one of their forms so again we have a
subscriber pop-up you've probably seen
some of these on some of the websites
you've gone to
so you can customize it and if you want
somebody to subscribe to your newsletter
for example all they need to do is enter
in their email address and click
subscribe okay that's the the pop-up
version now again you have the
opportunity to
you know use other forms as well so you
got a form builder here or an embedded
form okay where you can integrate the
form okay so if i click form
integrations here i can use wufoo or
squarespace i can integrate with them if
i go back to signup forms if i choose
form builder here i have a sign up form
and then i can customize that form with
different boxes okay or fields okay so
whatever field i want somebody to add
information to i can have that in there
and then this form could be you know on
your website so that's a great feature
about mailchimp is it helps you build an
audience so i can add this form to my
website and anybody who fills out that
form is going to be added to
my subscriber list that i can use for
future emails to take that a step
further i can even go from building a
form to building a landing page so here
you can see if i click on audience i can
go ahead at the bottom right here i have
an option to create a landing page so if
i click on that just like everything
else in mailchimp it's fairly easy to
use i'm just going to name it test click
begin here i can choose my audience
again i can what audience do i want to
add these emails to i click begin and
i'm going to accept and here now i have
all these different templates that i can
use as a landing page so if you want to
use these landing pages to collect
emails and those emails are going to be
added to your audience then you have a
nice selection here at your disposal
okay so here i'm just gonna choose one
you know grow my list okay this is a
landing page so i can customize it just
like i do with my email template i can
add my logo okay i can start adding
different fields here like an image i
can drop an image here okay i can go
ahead and
you know drop in my social shares okay i
can drop in a box text box okay and then
i can start customizing it with some
text some imagery you know some other
information again this is a landing page
that i can then add to my website and so
anytime somebody goes to the landing
page and fills out their email address
and hits subscribe it's going to be
added to that audience list and then i
can turn around and send an email using
one of mailchimp's templates to that
audience so mailchimp really does a
great job of allowing you to grow your
list within your own website via a
landing page a form submission or or
forum or pop-up so there are lots of
different options available to us so i'm
going to click save and close here and
now this landing page is available to me
so i can customize the url i can edit
the audience that these emails go to i
can add a page title and again i can
edit the design so i can really make
this an integrated part of my website by
designing it so it fits the feel and
look of my website i can add a specific
url and i can add a nice page title to
it so mailchimp again does a great job
of just making it so easy for you to
build out a landing page for you to use
on your website to collect email
addresses so if you're doing a
pay-per-click campaign on facebook or
google you can actually drive traffic to
these landing pages and get people to
fill out a form submission and when they
fill out the form submission that email
address is going to get added to your
audience that's an option or you can
just add it as part of your website and
people who go there from say organic
search can find that page and add their
email address organically so that's a
great thing about the audience feature
in mailchimp and that not only can you
select an email template but you have
options to grow your audience okay again
importing contacts you can simply just
add contacts you can add you know a form
submission via pop-up or regular form
fields to your website or you can add a
landing page so it's important to note
that in mailchimp if you go to the
content studio that's where you're gonna
find all the files that you've added to
all your templates or landing pages that
you used before so if i click on content
studio here here you can see the files
i've added to my templates if you have
products you can add your products here
okay so if you have an e-commerce store
you can certainly add your products and
then those products can be used on your
landing page or your email templates you
have something called a giphy you can
insert these into any of your emails
make it fun exciting engaging here you
have instagram so what you could do is
you can integrate you know any one of
your instagram accounts if you have
multiple accounts or via one instagram
account you can integrate that one
instagram account in with your mailchimp
account and when you do that it's going
to pull in all the images that you've
had on instagram and then you have an
opportunity here just to add a logo okay
so you can use any of your instagram
images within your emails use one of
these cool giffies again you can import
your products that you can use for your
email templates or just keep tabs on all
the files that you've added before just
by clicking on my files now when you get
to the point of
building different audience lists and
sending out emails you're going to have
the option to look at reporting to see
how those emails perform for those
specific audiences now again an audience
is a set it's like a segment you know
these are set of individuals who are
going to receive a specific email so in
this example you can see i have
different audiences and if we look at
say any one of these audience or even
just go to all audiences we'll be able
to see
how we fared on some of our emails okay
so for example if i send out an email
here in april and this is april of 2019
i could see how many total subscribers
i've had now along with the number of
subscribers you have you have what we
call open rate
and click-through rate now we explain a
lot of the reporting and the specific
email metrics and another recording that
we did last week so if you're interested
in learning more about some of the
metrics then check out the video that we
have on youtube email marketing tutorial
uh we recorded this last week go into
details about all the different metrics
you
uh can learn about with email marketing
so take a look at this video email
marketing tutorial it'll be a nice
precursor to the mailchimp tutorial so
to give you some insights as to what
metrics to really pay attention to with
email marketing but in mailchimp we know
we can look at the total number of
subscribers we know that we have how
many opens and we know what the open
rate is and again the total number of
clicks and what the click-through rate
is okay so with mailchimp very easily
you just hover over it you get the raw
number and then the percentage so open
rate is how many people actually open
that email based on the total number of
people that the email was sent to so
here we could see in this particular
email last year in april you know we've
had fourteen percent fourteen one point
one percent to be exact and that is
thirteen thousand three hundred seventy
seven divided by ninety seven thousand
four sixty nine so that's how many
people open the email so thirteen
thousand out of ninety seven is about 14
now when somebody opens it we hope
they're going to click on it and so here
we got a
1.4 percent click-through rate again
that's the total number of clicks based
on the total number of subscribers or
people that were sent the email and so
mailchimp just gives you a nice overview
of how many subscribers were in this
particular audience list and then the
open rating click rate so we can really
dive in here and we can actually see how
that particular email performs so if we
just pick one email here we can just
click view report we have other options
here we can print we can download we can
share it the whole campaign or just view
the email if we want to view what the
email look like we select that but we
just want to view the report so we're
going to click view report and now we
can get into some nice detailed
information about the actual report
itself so again here you can see total
number of recipients and this came from
the audience list called newsletter okay
was delivered last year september 26
2018 again i have the option to view it
download it print it or share it so
let's take a look and view the email to
see what it looked like okay so this is
what the email look like we have our own
template here and here you can see it
takes into account some of the best
practices
involved with email marketing you know
we have some nice content imagery some
call to action here some other links
okay we have our social icons okay so
that's what the email look like okay so
we'll go back and we're gonna click view
report now we want to view the report
again here's what it look here's when it
was sent okay the open rate for this was
21
click-through rate was 4
so for us the list average this list
here newsletter the average was for the
open rate 16.8 percent so we're above
the average on this email for the
click-through rate the list average is
2.7 so we're above the average so
we've done a good job on this email at
least generating more opens more clicks
and mailchimp even takes that a step
further they'll even show you what the
industry average is for your particular
industry and in this case we're
education and training so we did better
than the industry average for both the
open rate and for the click-through rate
so we could see some other specifics we
could see the raw numbers of opens
clicks how many people bounced meaning
the email address wasn't valid anymore
and so mailchimp does a good job of any
email that actually bounces it'll be
scrubbed and removed from your list and
then here you can see 347 unsubscribe so
the the thing about you know mailchimp
is we want to be careful we don't have
too many unsubscribes and also people
abusing or reporting abuse meaning you
don't want to send out an email multiple
multiple times a week where it gets the
point where it's spammy and so you want
to avoid a high number of unsubscribes
and a high number of abuse reports and
so here you can see
most emails are open within a 24-hour
period and then it kind of just tails
off so here we can see opens and clicks
based on the time of day so within
24-hour period okay so this is how most
emails operate within that first 24
hours you're going to get a lot of opens
a lot of clicks and then it's going to
tail off from there great thing is
mailchimp provides me more detailed
information about what was clicked so i
could see here the top links that were
clicked and let me just point one thing
out here
whether you use mailchimp or you use any
other platform whether that be vertical
response or any other type of email
marketing platform you want to use utm
tracking with your links so that google
analytics can pick up the actual
campaign so here you can see we have utm
tracking appended to our links and let
me just go in to detail on that for just
a minute so mailchimp again gives us
nice data on open and click-through
rates but when we send out an email and
people actually do click on one of these
links they're going to go to our website
and from there google analytics is going
to take over on the tracking so this is
as far as mailchimp goes so we want to
be able to bridge the gap between
mailchimp reporting and google analytics
meaning when they came from the
email when and went to the site did they
convert meaning did they download
something did they purchase something
and so we want to be able to bridge the
gap and utm tracking which is simply
appending the original url with some
tracking parameters named utm
it allows us to bridge that gap so all
you need to do when you set up a
mailchimp campaign is just go to url
builder in google then you're going to
click on campaign url builder and we're
going to go ahead and set up an email
campaign so for example if we go back
here this was the original url so if i
just copy this original url here and
paste that as part of my website url
what's my campaign source i'm going to
put mailchimp what's my medium i'm going
to put email so mailchimp is the source
of where the traffic came from the
medium the means in which they
arrived at our website was via email and
the campaign name we're just gonna put
maybe whatever it is summer promo so
with the url builder you have five
parameters for utm tracking you don't
have to use all five okay so here we
need to put in the url and we need to
put in the source but the other four
parameters medium name term and content
are optional so you don't have to put
anything there but the more parameters
you put in the more specific it is for
you to track the behavior of that email
campaign so here i can see mailchimp
email summer promo and then for the
content i can use that to differentiate
my subject lines so when you send out an
email we mention this in the email
marketing tutorial you always want to
send out multiple subject lines meaning
one list gets one subject line another
list gets this a second subject line
because you want to be able to measure
open rates based on subject lines so i
can use the campaign content parameter
for different subject lines and notice
the url builder once i enter in my
parameters it's going to append the
original url with a new url appended
with utm tracking so if i copy that i
can simply just paste that in my browser
just to see if it works and here you can
see it works the page loaded the
original url with utm tracking and so
that's exactly what you want to do
because when you're looking at your
reports in mailchimp it's going to show
me the top links that were clicked now
if i go into analytics i want to be able
to see how that campaign or how that
link actually performed so let's take a
look at that real quick so if i go to my
google analytics account and i go to
acquisition campaigns all campaigns what
am i looking for well if i click on
source and medium source and medium are
to the parameters for utm tracking i'm
going to look for mailchimp so here i
can see
my original url mailchimp and then the
date stamp and then the medium's email
so if i go back here i can see for
example any one of these mailchimp
emails that went out and then i can see
how many people actually came from the
email what the balance rate was meaning
if they arrived on the site did they
leave after arriving or they actually go
to another page and then i could see
other engagement data like how many
pages they looked at did they how much
time do they spend more importantly did
they convert so that's the whole idea
behind using utm tracking because with
utm tracking you can can bridge the gap
from open rate click through rate to
behavior on the website all the way
through to the conversion and that's
what we want to measure we want to
measure did somebody go from the email
open it click on one of the links go to
the website engage on the website and
convert and so that's the whole idea
behind utm tracking because mailchimp
and any other email marketing platform
is only going to give you at most your
open rates and your click-through rates
okay so here we could see the top links
clicked i see 4 000
recipients clicked on this email they
went to the site and now i need
analytics to kind of tell me the rest
and here i can see what subscribers have
the most opens and if i integrated
social i can see some social performance
and so that goes back to our original
setup so if you integrate your twitter
account or your facebook account you'll
be able to
integrate that email in with your
twitter and then from there i'll be able
to see you know tweets or or how many
likes for example and to top it off i
can see how many people from around the
world clicked on the email so that's
reporting in a nutshell on mailchimp
reports are fairly easy to look at you
know all sorts of other information like
links specifically links uh you can look
at social so if i click on the social
tab here if i integrated my social i can
look at social reporting likewise for
e-commerce and notice analytics 360 i
can integrate google analytics in with
mailchimp if i want to so i have all
sorts of options on my reporting so
that's it for mailchimp i mean it's
fairly easy to navigate you have all the
campaigns that you've sent out so if you
just click on campaigns i'll be able to
see all the campaigns i've set up and
all the campaigns that have been sent
and obviously the ones that have been
sent i can start looking at reports i
can pick and choose templates okay i can
pick and choose my audience and manage
my audience okay i can see what the
growth is from my audience again i have
different options to grow my audience
okay i can certainly add form
submissions landing pages
sign up forms i can import more contacts
and i can manage them through different
lists content studio is where all your
files are going to be located from the
files you've uploaded to e-commerce
products to getfeeds to instagram to my
logo and then you have reports and the
reports are there for you to measure the
performance of your email campaigns once
they've been sent so you can look at
them from reports or just from the main
campaigns view that's pretty much it so
if you're ready to go at it again click
that create button click that template
choose that audience you can go ahead
and send yourself that test email when
you're ready go ahead and send that
email off to your audience it's that
simple in mailchimp we're going to cover
the email marketing interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's going to work so if
you have any questions to these
questions or answers feel free to just
comment right below this video and we'll
get back to you as soon as possible
we're gonna go through a series of
questions and i'm gonna answer those
questions for you so email marketing's
traditional digital marketing channel
it's been around a while and you're
going to be asked some questions that
are going to encompass a lot of things
related to the delivery of emails we all
check emails on a daily basis we all
receive them sometimes we receive emails
unsolicited sometimes we sign up to
receive emails sometimes we receive
emails from friends sometimes we receive
emails where we're working or previously
have worked so most people have an
understanding of email however as a
marketer there's a little bit of a
different twist to it so we have to
understand the intricacies of how email
marketing works so you're gonna be asked
some questions and really the first
question here is what's the difference
between a hard and a soft balanced email
so if you're a digital marketer you're
in charge of sending out
lots of emails let's just say thousands
or i mean it could be in the hundreds of
thousands of emails you're gonna get
some bounces and so you really want to
know the difference between a hard and a
soft bounce so a soft bounce just means
that the email message reached the
recipient's mail server but bounce back
is undelivered so think of it as
delivering an actual mail to a post
office so it actually reached the post
office but it bounced back because
maybe the
you know person's email box was full
maybe their account was temporarily
disabled or maybe the email server
wasn't necessarily able to handle that
email now hard balance is an email that
that is rejected because it's an email
when it happens when the email has been
permanently rejected so for example
maybe the
the the account is no longer valid and
so let's look at some reasons again as
to why a soft bounce would happen so for
example the inbox is full or
the recipient servers down so reach the
post office but there was a problem
actually getting it into the hands of
the owner so to speak where the hard
balance a little bit different let's
just say that person is no longer
working their email has been deleted or
you the email has been blacklisted
somehow okay a spam or something to that
effect so the email server is going to
identify that and it's not even going to
reach the recipient so
a lot of different ways in which an
email may not make its recipient so not
the most important thing to know here i
just the important thing to know is
listen when you send out an email you
got to pay attention to how many get
bounced back and so
next question here what would you do to
improve the click-through rate of your
email so click-through rate is simply
how many people have seen your email and
how many people actually clicked on a
link in the email so if a hundred people
saw your email but only one person
clicked then it would be a one percent
click-through rate so we want to be able
to make sure we have a high
click-through rate so remember emails
are going to people who likely signed up
to receive your email and even if they
are expecting an email or they're not
expecting an email you still want to
follow some of these best practices here
one is to create a compelling subject
line so you want to make the subject
line something that people are going to
notice take note of or take an interest
in and say hey what's this all about
that's pretty interesting and open the
email so use preview text effectively
obviously you want to make your email
mobile friendly because most people look
at their emails on their mobile phones
you want to create engaging content okay
so the content that's in the email
obviously is going to have some links so
put some strong call to action in there
and that's one of the bullet points down
below place a cta where it's easily
visible so keep in mind mobile users
most people are going to check that
email on their phone so you want to make
sure you have compelling content with
good ctas in a visible location so
always check mobile as well as desktop
obviously in your emails you want to
make them as visual as possible don't
make them so text heavy you can always
segment your emails meaning if you're
sending out an email let's just say to
100 people okay maybe you want to divide
it up boys or girls maybe older or young
maybe
you know living in one part of the
country versus another part of the
country i mean those are examples of
segments so break up the email don't
send it to
one mass email to everyone that way you
can personalize the email if an email is
personalized the chances of somebody
clicking on it are going to be greater
and then a b test your emails and when
we say a b test you know you could send
out the same email twice except one
segment's going to say get one version
of the email the other segment is going
to get another version of the email and
what are the different versions maybe
the subject line so the subject line is
different on version a versus version b
or maybe the call to action is different
so you always want to
send out different versions of the same
email to a different segmented audience
that way you can actually see
which segment or which version got the
most clicks okay so next question here
is how to inform your customers about
company news and establish a
relationship with your target audience
okay so again how do you inform your
customers about what's going on in the
company and how are you going to
establish a relationship with that
audience who's receiving that email well
newsletters are always the best answer
here so somebody signs up for your email
let's just say they actually purchase a
product from you newsletters are great
way to reach out to that audience to get
them to stay up to date with the latest
product or an improved version of the
product they purchased and then that way
they can come back and continue to
purchase the product so newsletters are
great way to reach out to
your audience and actually talk to your
audience and you're not talking verbally
you're talking to them via email so you
send out that email campaign maybe it's
once a month hey we noticed you bought
this product we have similar products
just like the one you bought or hey
you know if it's a software maybe hey
we've got upcoming updates to our
software make sure you go to the website
and get the updates or we have a new and
improved version so all these things you
want to communicate to your audience via
email that's going to get them to get to
the website and that's going to get them
to you know purchase more update upgrade
whatever so newsletters the way to go so
again some basic tips here you want to
create your newsletter with 90
educational and 10 percent promotional
so remember you're sending out a
newsletter to people who likely signed
up so you're educating them about your
products always create interesting
subject lines you want whether they know
you or not you want to create the
subject line so somebody's going to
click on it so
make sure you design your emails
appropriately okay so if you know you're
sending let's just say baby products to
mothers or expected mothers in fact this
is a real life example because i used to
work at a gap and
baby gap was you know one of the emails
groups i was responsible for so we
created an email template with softer
colors your yellows your your light
blues you know it wasn't black or dark
red or anything that's going to be you
know heavy we knew who our audience was
and we designed the template accordingly
and of course using compelling images so
for selling baby products you're going
to put baby product images in there i
mean it's common sense but you'd be
surprised you gotta pick and choose your
images carefully especially if you're
sending to an international audience
because images can be misconstrued and
just like we mentioned with the
click-through rate you always want to
have a clear cta always make sure you
have a cta in a visible position because
most people are going to look at that
email in a mobile phone okay and then
always make sure you include your
contact information in the newsletter so
somebody knows where to find you how to
contact you where to go maybe they have
a product they want to return okay so
you always want to put that contact
information normally it's at the bottom
of the email but these are all best
practices so here's some examples okay
we got you know check out the latest
cosmetics from our new collections
notice the image and notice the call to
action so you can see trendy collections
you know we got some other products you
may want to buy okay five important skin
care products that everyone should have
view more so you always want to have
that call to action
in a very visible place so define
following metrics open rate
click-through rate and response rate and
forward rate so these are metrics
related to email marketing so you're
going to have to know what these are so
we already mentioned click-through rate
before when we talked about best
practices for improving the
click-through rate so for those of you
that remember what that is go ahead and
put that in the comment section below
just a little pop quiz for you if
anybody remembers click-through rate but
let's take a look at open rate so open
rate is the percentage of the total
number of recipients who actually open
the email so if you send it to x amount
of people how many people opened it that
would be the open rate so how many
people open it but you're gonna take out
the people who balanced it whether it's
a soft bounds or hard bounce okay you're
not gonna count those people so
if you have let's just say
20 people open the email and you sent it
to a hundred people then and you had
nobody balanced then it would be a 20
open rate okay click-through rate again
pop quiz it's just how many people
actually clicked on any of the links in
your email and that's just divided by
the number of of the emails you've sent
out a response rate okay so response
rate is the percentage of the total
recipients who clicked on the link of
your email campaign and actually
complete it in action so what is that
action well it could be downloading
something watching something purchasing
something so that's the response rate
similar to conversion rate if you're
working in a digital marketing channel
and you're driving traffic to the site
you want that traffic to do something
well it's no different in email
marketing we want people to take action
we're just going to divide that by the
number of emails delivered and that
gives you your response rate so let's
just say you did send in 100 emails you
did get 20
open it and of this 20 let's just say
one person went on to purchase well
you'd have a one percent response rate
and then a ford rate is simply the
forward rate refers to the rate at which
your subscribers share your email uh
with others friends family etc and you
may have that as a call to action in
your email in fact that's a best
practice so it's just the number of
clicks on a share divided by the total
number of delivered emails and you're
going to multiply that by 100 to get the
percentage and so most email marketing
platforms do measure forward rate okay
let's take a look at how to recapture
inactive customers what you want to do
here is reengage subscribers with
gamification opt for subject lines like
we have been missing you or did we do
something wrong you want to run a poll
or a competition and re-engage their
subscribers again trying to get people
involved these first three are all about
getting people involved so personalize
your emails talk to that person as if
hey look i haven't heard from you in a
while how about coming back and taking a
look at our new products just as you
would a friend say design always matters
especially knowing that you're talking
to customers who haven't been active
okay this is a segmented audience
somebody who's inactive so you want to
have the right design the right message
the right subject line that fits with
that customer's inactivity so you want
to try and do everything you can to get
that customer back and then you want to
follow a consistent schedule okay so
ideally when you schedule an email you
want to schedule the best time so you
have to know your audience obviously and
then you can always ask for feedback why
are they inactive why haven't they
purchased in a while so the whole idea
here
from gamification like trying to
you know make a game out of it so make
it competitive to
adding polls to really personalizing it
these are all things that you can do to
get your customers back so what are the
different ways to segment buyer personas
so again when we talk about segmentation
we're talking about taking a smaller
piece the entire pie so what's one way
to break up that pie if you will by
geography okay so with geography you
could target your audience based on that
area and it could not necessarily have
to be by a part of the country it could
be all the way down to the province the
state the actual city the county okay if
you live in a small village okay all the
way up to the continent okay so think
about how you would break out the
segment by geography now obviously if
you break it out let's just say the
united states to the southern part well
the southern part you know in the winter
in the united states the southern part
is not going to be as cold to say the
northern part so that should tell you
hey we're going to send an
email in the winter we're not going to
use snow and blizzards as our theme
we're going to use probably a little bit
of sun so breaking it out by geography
helps you understand where your audience
lives you also have demographic
segmentation and this is simply just age
education income gender you know where
people work okay nationality anything
that's going to identify that user so
this is the best way to segment if you
know who your audience is by income or
gender i mean you're talking to a group
of like-minded people if they're all the
same age from the same generation then
you could talk to them appropriately and
you're not going to talk to
an older person the same way you would a
younger person so think about
demographic segmentation because it
really helps you hone in on your
messaging and you have behavioral
segmentation so behavioral is based on
your audience's behavior have they
purchased before have they never
purchased were they searching for
something how long did they stay on the
site what products were they looking at
are they a lifetime customer so you can
look at behavior and decide how you want
to break out your emails by behavior and
this is a really good way if you're not
even sure who your audience is or where
they live and how old they are you could
certainly break out your audience by
behavior because you know who these
people are based on what they've done
previously because you're going to track
that information with analytics so you
know one way is obviously if somebody's
purchased that's a good way to segment
because you know these people believe in
you believe in your business believe in
your product so the way you can message
to somebody who's purchased before is
going to be different than somebody you
don't even know who they are if they
purchased or not okay so behavioral
segmentation to me is one of the easiest
things the easiest ways to segment your
email list how would you drive repeat
customers through email marketing for
the below scenario okay so this is a pop
quiz if you will again for those of you
that got click-through rate correctly
kudos let's see if you can go two for
two here okay so if you know the answer
to this go ahead and comment below but
let's just say give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for
audiences based on the following so if i
had an audience between 20 and 30 years
old that were female and the product
were sandals okay what would some of
your subject lines be so i'm going to
give you a minute to think about that
and put it in the comment section below
now remember this is an interview based
question so you're gonna have to think
on the spot i'm gonna give you a minute
but if somebody presented that to you in
an interview you need to be able to you
know react fairly quickly and come up
with some really attractive subject
lines here okay so here you go here's
another one uh so give a few examples of
subject lines to drive engagement for 20
to 30 females for footwear so you got
friday sale coming up buy branded
sandals at the lowest price
okay so i like this one because it's got
a strong call to action buy here you go
this is even better because 50 off on
branded sandals and free shipping i mean
who can't beat free anything including
shipping and if it's 50 off i mean these
are key things you're putting the
promotion and percentage off all in the
subject line so that's really going to
grab somebody's attention weekend sale
for women starts now okay with a little
emoji that never hurts so those are all
good subject lines they all tend to work
because they all have an element of a
best practice in there so
here you got you know the friday sale
coming up is just giving people notice
okay the stronger call to action on the
buy you're putting the promotion in the
subject line and you know using an emoji
to really just drive home the point so
all these subject lines will work and
hey at the end of the day remember you
want to test your subject lines okay
moving on to the next question speaking
of testing what is a b testing and give
some examples of a b testing okay so we
talked a little bit about a b testing
with subject lines so simply a b testing
when it comes to email marketing it's
just a method to analyze which of the
two email campaign strategies is most
effective all right you know you're
going to do it based on open rate you
can do it by saying click rate you can
do it based on response rate and
remember you're putting one version of
the email against another version
whether that be the subject line whether
it be the content call to action
whatever so that's ideally what you're
trying to do you're trying to figure out
what works for your audience that's the
end goal for email for a b testing and
email marketing what's going to work and
i would highly suggest you should always
do a b testing for subject lines always
so some of the variables that you can
test again subject lines okay you always
want to try if you got a promotion hey
will the percentage off work likely it
will but let's test it up against
something else like you know a generic
word like discounts you can always test
the design you can always test the
personalization the preview text you
could try out images call to actions
exclusive offers what particular offer
is going to work okay so if you're
testing offers then obviously that's
going to be response rate if you're
testing ctas and that's going to be
click-through rate if you're testing
subject lines that's going to be open
rate so you want to be able to test
different elements of the email to
figure out what works and what doesn't
work okay so how to prevent email from
getting into spam so if you're an email
marketer this is your worst nightmare
you don't want your emails to get
spammed so that doesn't bode well for
you so most email marketing platforms
like mailchimp or constant contact
measure spam so some of the important
ways to prevent this is hey improve your
open rate remember going back to the
first question second question you want
to have really good subject lines here
okay and you want to segment your
audience so if you're if you know who
you're talking to and you have a cool
subject line that's going to get
somebody to react and open and that's
going to prevent somebody from spamming
your email okay you can always customize
your from to make it look like it's
coming from in this case rob sanders
check if you have included an
unsubscribe link okay so get people the
option to unsubscribe they don't have
the option to unsubscribe they could
just report you as spam make sure your
emails work on different devices and you
want to optimize your images for email
make sure they're not big and they don't
fit on a mobile device okay prefer more
text and fewer images and then avoid
grammatical issues you want to come
across as professional you don't want
somebody looking at your email like who
sent this why you sending this to me i
don't want to hear from you again i'm
going to spam you you want to prevent
that and that means a professional
looking email professional content with
a really good subject line and some
imagery to go along with that hey you
may just get somebody to open that email
and get them to convert that's the idea
behind it so these are ways to prevent
somebody from actually spamming you and
then what are the best practices for
email subject lines so the subject line
is the most probably the most important
element in email marketing so we talked
about that little pop quiz with the
sandals targeting 20 to 30 year old
women you know to me i like the subject
line with the 50 off so that was a
number in the subject line so people can
actually see hey wow i get a whole 50
percent that works better than just a
discount okay remember one of those
other subject lines had an emoji so
don't be afraid to include emojis in
there for example when i send out emails
using you know during the spring you
might want to use flowers perhaps to
signify hey it's spring winter's over so
personalize the subject lines remember
that goes with segmenting so if you know
who your audience is your subject lines
can be a little bit more personal okay
so off for title case subject lines okay
so instead of making it grammatical for
example okay you want to keep your
subject lines short and to the point
remember you want to say something
that's going to draw somebody's
attention if you make it long and drawn
out and boring then people aren't going
to open it develop a sense of urgency
like hey we got 50 off through friday so
that's a little sense of urgency so
people know hey if it's thursday i
better open this email and check it out
and again grammatical mistakes that goes
without saying you always want to
preview your emails before you send them
out so if you preview your emails before
you send them out have somebody else
obviously receive the preview they can
be another set of eyes for you to
prevent any mistakes but also give you
feedback on the imagery the design etc
okay so these are all best practices for
good subject lines okay so subject line
is the most important element for email
marketing so just keep these in mind
subject lines and having good subject
lines is the way to get people to open
it and from there that's half the battle
somebody can open the email then you've
just set yourself up for better
performance
welcome to this content marketing full
course by simply learn we'll begin this
full course by understanding what
content marketing is and some of its
popular strategies then we will see how
content marketing affects seo and we'll
understand how to rank number one on
google and youtube by creating high
quality content
then we will look into the top 10
important content marketing interview
questions and answers
at the end we will look into minor
concepts like a simple beginner's guide
to content marketing and introduction to
content marketing certification training
by the end of this video i can assure
you that all your content marketing
career related queries would have been
answered for this training with me i
have our experienced content marketing
specialist rob and greg jabo together
they will take you through the various
topics of content marketing so without
any further ado let's get started before
we begin make sure to subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simplylearn
greetings everyone and welcome my name
is rob sanders from simply learn and
today we're going to talk about content
marketing strategy
so buckle up and let's get right to it
and we're going to get right into some
of the best practices some tips some
methodologies some things you should be
doing with content marketing so right
out of the gate let's start talking
about
knowing your audience okay so content is
all about
writing for a particular audience so
it's just like speaking except when
we're speaking to somebody we're
speaking directly to them content is
very similar and so we have to be able
to know our audience ahead of time so
what you can do is collect demographics
of your target audience based on
who's coming to your website so you can
get that data in google analytics under
audience email subscribers i mean
who is subscribing to your emails who do
you already have in your email database
and you can look at social media i mean
you look at facebook you can look at the
people who are already connected to you
okay these are just some three three of
many examples you could be doing to
gather data on your audience okay you
have to know who your audience is before
you start writing you know for a
successful content marketing strategy
you really just need to know your
audience and basically you're going to
segment them based on their interest so
that content is going to be catered to
that audience okay so if it's science
that likes a specific
you know product uh that you offer or
feature
that's part of that product that you
offer then that's the segment you're
going to be writing about so you need to
collect your data on your audience ahead
of time then you're going to segment
that audience okay so you're not going
to write content for everyone because
the shoe doesn't necessarily fit for
everyone okay the shoe has to fit for
specific foot and in this case we're
talking about an audience we need to be
able to segment our audience out and you
could certainly segment them out by age
by gender by education level by income
by interest i mean these are just some
of the examples again it could be new
returning or new reusers versus
returning users it could be users who
have purchased from you in the past
versus users who haven't purchased from
you in the past
it could certainly be
an age range or it could be even going
further on interest level or combination
thereof okay so for example you can get
that demographic information using
google analytics
just got to go in the analytics under
audience under demographics you're going
to see age and br its age is broken out
by age range and they're going to see
gender so you're going to see a
breakdown of gender and use that to your
advantage so if you're going to
you know write some content and you know
99 of your traffic is female the age of
18 to 24 then you know that content's
been catered accordingly so we could
certainly go to facebook page insights
and get some really good demographic
data there because facebook is all about
demographics okay so
you could see exactly you know how many
fans you have broken out by men versus
women and then you can see again same
thing as google analytics you could see
an age range breakout you could use
twitter analytics i mean twitter has
shared some really good insights into
education level so you know if you're
dealing with you know highly
sophisticated people who have master's
degrees or even higher or let's just say
even on linkedin you know that majority
of the people you're trying to target
are c level meaning ceos or cfos or cmos
you know chief marketing officers or
chief executive officers then you're
going to cater your message a little bit
different than say mid-range managers or
or you know even high-range managers or
even vps so use your audience
information you collect on these various
platforms to your advantage okay so
let's jump into number two we want to
create high quality content now i know
this sounds like a given but
and i say but heavily there's not a lot
of high quality content out there on the
internet so separate yourself first and
foremost always always always create
high quality content it's going to
result in a lot of things that are going
to benefit you you know one you're gonna
come across as you know somebody who
knows what they're talking about and
that's gonna help increase your brand
awareness okay when you increase your
brand awareness people know about you so
it's likely going to increase traffic to
your website or if you're on social
media you know if you produce good high
quality content people are gonna share
that content okay so
from an seo perspective it can improve
website ranking meaning if you have good
quality content you know and it's really
focused in on a specific topic or a
certain set of core words keywords then
you're gonna rank improves website dwell
time meaning hey you get good content
people are gonna hang around to see what
else you have to offer okay so it's no
secret that you know good content you
usually leads to you know quality
engagement and then
certainly last but not least you can
gain a lot of leads here meaning hey
somebody likes what you have to say
whether it's a video or blog post or or
infographic you know people are going to
become more interested more engaged
spend more time and that's all going to
funnel through to somebody taking that
next step in the funnel and
becoming more interested in your service
or even purchasing one of your products
so creating high quality content
involves brainstorming topics and terms
you know you got to do the upfront work
due diligence is at work here so
brainstorm some topics use a keyword
research tool to gather results so if
you have a topic you know one of the
benefits of quality content is rankings
go to google's keyword planner
understand how much quality
and and understand how much competition
each keyword has or understand how much
volume each keyword has that's what's
available in google's keyword plan or
any really any keyword planning tool you
always want to create original content
okay so you don't want to plagiarize or
take somebody else's content and then
you want to support that content with
compelling headlines so if you have a
piece of content you got to get
somebody's attention
write a nice headline that's going to
grab their attention okay so give
valuable content to readers and add
resources from well-known sites so if
you you do borrow say
a data point from another source then
you know cite that source you also want
to create engaging and thought provoking
content get somebody to think i mean
people are going to rage your content
because they not they don't know the
subject matter their interests in the
subject matter and they want to be able
to spend the time taking something away
from that content follow a logical
structure and use relevant images i
can't stress this one enough you know
just throw things on a web page you know
put some structure to it maybe you have
to break it out if you feel like you
have too much content there's no harm in
breaking it into part one versus part
two get people uh tease them a bit get
them to come back and read part two okay
use different content forms in case
somebody's interested maybe you want to
capture some data you know prefer short
paragraphs to make the content readable
remember if you're talking to c-level
folks you know maybe you don't have to
dummy down the content so to speak but
if you're dealing with you know folks or
people that are right out of high school
or still in high school then adjust your
content in format and paragraphs
accordingly and then update the content
as well just because you publish it
doesn't mean that it's done i mean when
we're talking about a web page we're
talking about something that is actively
changing or can change the medium that
is dynamic okay so if a data points
change go back in and update that data
point and then let people know about it
because they may want to come back and
and you know check in to see how much
that data points change so these are all
you know good takeaways for creating
high quality content there's some other
things that you should be aware of you
know grammatical mistakes you know you
need to avoid those there's no reason
for grammatical mistakes today's
technology doesn't allow for it and hey
listen we all have friends we have
colleagues my desk is sitting next to a
colleague who's more than happy to read
something before it gets published so
take advantage of the resources you have
available no reason for it because if
you have a grammatical mistake you've
just lost a lot of credibility you know
don't be afraid to add a clear call to
action at the end of your content if
somebody's interested in reading it
they're probably going to be interested
in taking the next step whatever that
next step is okay so creating content
that fulfills viewers requirements
meaning if somebody's searching for
something and your content shows up in
the search results then they're actively
looking for you what are you offering
them is it fulfilling their requirements
you know don't be afraid to use examples
throughout your content in fact work in
or integrate some case studies in there
show clear examples to stress your
points
and then just don't put words on a web
page you know to break up that content
with an image that's going to be
visually appealing okay and you can add
images from public domain sites meaning
stock imagery if that's what's going to
help
create visually appealing content and
then give more information to your
audience and we say prefer to give more
information meaning hey going back to
the content i was saying about breaking
it up organizing it if you have more
information
don't withhold it have them come back
and read a secondary blog post or
secondary piece that supports the
original now we want to move from high
quality content to running a b test baby
test so important why because with a b
split testing you can increase your
conversion rates okay so
four elements to test in your content
marketing strategy so if you have
content say a blog and you're testing
that blog you know test out the images
test out the forms do you have a long
form or short form you know test out the
content length you can have a variation
that is a lot shorter than the original
does that increase or decrease bounce
rates play around with call to actions
your call to actions do matter you know
do you want to use a softer call to
action a softer tone or do you want to
use something very direct and strong you
know test call to actions to see what's
going to get people to move closer
through the
closer to purchasing and through that
funnel so a b testing to me is something
that should be naturally done with
google optimize it's free so with images
you know you could test a lot of
different variations of images anything
from people
to
you know outlandish imagery to just
something very stock and neutral but
just make sure that those images are
relevant to the post you know test the
length of that content you know again if
you know that your average time on page
is very low
you know don't write something very long
write something that you think is going
to stick with that time on page but on
your a b test create something maybe a
little longer if it's engaging enough
maybe somebody's going to stay a little
bit longer on the page so
you know create a variation it's going
to play with that length okay so use
analytics to your advantage to figure
out
as a baseline what amount of content is
getting people to stay on the page then
see if you can push the envelope one way
or the other okay improving the page
with sign up forms really what you want
to do is create a user friendly
experience so when you have sign up
forms and don't make them non-intuitive
don't make them difficult you know link
maybe up to facebook or google so
if they're creating an account they can
create an account via google or facebook
or you know don't put too many forms on
the page and then on those ctas as i
mentioned play around with the tone you
can also play around the color i mean i
test color all the time believe it or
not color does matter don't use red use
green people react to different colors
but again you have cultural variances as
well so you got to take that into
account if you're in the middle east or
the far east asia you know color schemes
and what you say matters and it changes
versus say you know europe or the west
okay so keep that in mind when you're
making changes on color or tone or
placement and things of that nature so
you want to conduct a competitor
analysis so we're talking about creating
high quality content testing that
content you know brainstorming some
topics you know looking at your audience
you're doing all this work you might as
well take the next step and figure out
what it is your competitors are doing so
you can opt for competitive analysis by
identifying your competitor's top
performing content for specific topics
okay and so
really what we're trying to do here is
improve our conversion rates so what are
your competitors doing what are their
baselines we can maybe up that annie i
mean that data is also available in
google analytics so you can look at
benchmarking reports in google analytics
to get some form or fashion you can also
go to facebook and look at your
competitors facebook pages and see
what's performing in terms of engagement
but what you want to do is find out your
strongest competitors by using search
engines or check which websites are
competing with you and again that could
include facebook as well or maybe even
linkedin so you go with the search
engine route you can always type in that
coveted keyword that you want to be
found for see who's ranking ahead of you
and you can see the metadata meaning the
title tag and the meta description you
can actually see hey what are these guys
writing that's getting them recognized
in the search engine rankings so you can
certainly if you go to search engine
route you could certainly leverage an
seo platform like search
sem rush or moz or something like that
that's going to allow you to get some
good insight on competitor information
so keep in mind there are seo platforms
that will give you information on your
competitors and that's what these seo
platforms are good for so number five
moving on choose a suitable content
format so
now we've done all this homework we know
what we want to say we know who we want
to say it to we're ready to do some
testing but we need to find a format
because it's not always about a web page
per se meaning content on a web page
there's not always about a blog post
with content in that blog post okay we
need to decide the type of content
that's going to fit what we're trying to
say so again you can go the traditional
route with just posting a blog post and
there's nothing wrong with that because
with a blog post you can incorporate
video and imagery you could also go a
more harder route when i say harder more
let's say official route with an e-book
or case study something that a user is
going to be able to take away with maybe
download okay something more
official um something more in-depth
something with a harder stamp on it so
that that shows individuals that you've
taken the time you've done this homework
you've done this research you've done
some really in-depth analysis and now
the proper format for that is not a blog
post it's an ebook now if you're into
talking
like i am then you can certainly do a
podcast and podcasts are always popular
depending on the topic so you got to be
aware of the topic now videos are always
always a good option you got the likes
of video and video and youtube and some
other you know video platforms out there
that allow you the ability to get found
very quickly especially with the likes
of youtube you know people use youtube
before they go on to purchasing a
product so think about that so if you're
trying to get somebody if you're trying
to sway an audience to
move from being a brand awareness and a
loyal you know customer to taking the
next step okay to purchasing more or
purchasing for the first time and so
videos kind of help convey that now if
you're trying to convey a lot of
different points then an infographic
might be your best option instead of
having to write out all those points you
know try using an infographic to convey
those points visually now again with
blog posts it should have valuable
content that can be shared by your
website
visitors on social so that's the key
make sure you have those shareable
social icons now with ebooks it should
have longer in-depth content so and it
shouldn't be published frequently so
maybe if this is something you're doing
annually then ebook could be the format
with a case study what you should have a
customer story that succeeded in and you
solving that customer's problem so the
case study is always there for
you know somebody to get an idea of what
you're all about infographic is just
visualizing data in a more organized way
in a more visual way so somebody
understands what you're trying to convey
now with that podcast again suppose your
audience doesn't have an interest in
reading again it could be a certain age
certain gender a certain culture
hey everybody absorbs information
differently so think about it ask
yourself is a podcast the best way to
communicate to my target audience and
then videos are highly engaging they're
also shareable on blog posts and pretty
much most if not all social media
platforms so once you've done that once
you choose the proper format you want to
choose a content management system
that's going to work for you so you want
to be able to choose something where you
can plan appropriately produce manage
publish and measure results all in one
place there are plenty of content
management systems out there that will
help you do all of those things okay so
some examples are wordpress hubspot
binder i mean we can list hundreds if
you're into blogging you know wordpress
is the way to go if you're into building
out landing pages that you want to you
know share
you know hotspot could be the way to go
okay there are lots of available options
out there so moving on number seven
target your audience using emails okay
so what are we talking about well we all
know what emails are emails help us to
communicate directly with our target
audience and convert them to leads so
email is a good way to follow up with
your audience so if you've done a
podcast follow up with an email you
maybe get them to you know fill out a
survey via email based on that podcast
or
if you create a podcast about some data
that you talked about in that podcast
follow up that with with them via email
with an infographic perhaps okay built
into the email okay there's lots of ways
that all these formats can complement
themselves via email okay you could
certainly take a blog post and package
it into an email and have a link
pointing back to the blog post maybe as
a teaser or if you're doing a series a
series of blog posts you know you could
tease that in an email so an email is a
good way to you know follow up with your
target audience indirectly or directly
when we say indirectly
you know you can collect emails and send
out those emails with you know certain
information or what you should be doing
is targeting and segmenting your emails
just like you are your content so if
you're producing content for certain
audience then make sure that particular
audience gets that same email now some
of the email content that you could
share with your targeting audience are
newsletters okay seasonal emails
promotional emails automated messaging
and what we mean by automated messaging
hey if somebody just purchased from you
send them a thank you email maybe follow
up a couple days later with another
email with a survey or
what you could do is if you know who
your loyal customers are you target them
with a promotional email so there's lots
of ways to slice and dice content via
email okay just make sure you know your
target audience is there's lots of
things you can do in email again you can
complement lots of different formats
within email as i mentioned before with
a podcast or a blog post so keep all
that in mind email's a good way to
communicate with your audience okay the
last point we want to make here is use
native ads okay so we talk about native
ads it's one of the smartest ways to
connect your audience with your brand so
for example this is a native ad on
buzzfeed okay it's about 15 bands that
probably won't exist without led
zeppelin okay so for you folks out there
that don't know who led zeppelin is a
rock group from the 70s late 60s 70s
okay disbanded in 80 81 82 early 80s
okay but you know people grew up like
myself listening to led zeppelin okay so
you can see the headline here 15 bands
that probably won't exist with the
outlet zeppelin you know i'm interested
in who those bands might be even if you
don't know who led zeppelin is okay you
might be inquisitive to say okay
who is this led zeppelin group and what
are these 15 bands the key here is not
to say the headline or led zeppelin per
se but it's a native ad and it's sitting
next to
content talking about music okay so
according to forbes online audiences are
25 more likely to look at a native ad
than at a banner and so that native ad
in this case we're talking about music
needs to be sitting or accompanied
alongside content talking about in this
case music you know would help if it was
rock music just music in general might
get enough to get peak people's interest
okay so if you're going to create
content you know align that content with
something that's you know naturally
going to fit and that's why we call them
native ads because they're native to the
content that they're associated with so
finally after all that's said and done
when all you've done is create good
content follow up via emails targeting
your audience and associating that
content with you know content natively
then you can always measure your content
performance so
my favorite part of it all you going to
analytics going to facebook insights you
know you want to go in and check out how
that content is performing and you want
to do that because
you want to be able to see what's
performing what's not performing the key
here is associating
the content with kpis that's really the
key so measuring the right metrics can
help you understand whether your content
is engaging or not so again measuring
the right metrics okay so when we're
talking about a video
you're not necessarily going to look at
page views you're going to look at video
views so you know some of these basic
metrics of users and sessions and pages
bounce rate you know dwell time that's
all great but you just need to make sure
that
you're aligning the right metric with
the right asset so for example if you
have a case study or ebook you want to
make sure that
you're measuring how many downloads the
ebook or the
case study received again with the video
you want to measure video views now if
you're packaging up emails and sending
them out to your target audience you
want to make sure you look at open rates
and click rates okay so a lot of things
you can be looking at so make sure you
choose the right metrics because there's
hundreds and hundreds of metrics to
choose from so just be aware all the
different metrics that are available you
know if you're in it for search okay how
much traffic getting from search where
are you ranking so a lot of things you
need to think about so think about the
content that you're producing and think
about how you want to be able to measure
that content so let's go back over our
checklist here
so
what you could do is create an editorial
calendar in fact i would highly suggest
you create an editorial calendar in
order to keep track of all the content
you've done over a period of time are
you making your content worth reading
that means are you
checking the results of that content
what we just went over measuring the
content is it worth reading have a
column set up in that editorial calendar
you know performing or not performing if
it's not performing don't do it again
okay curate your content okay you always
want to you know make sure you're
reusing or using or adding to the
content that you've created guest post
on influential blogger websites you want
to add statistics numbers and quotes to
your content make it engaging make it
look like you've done your homework you
could share all your content not just on
social media but you know platforms like
slideshare now you can share it on all
social media platforms i'd highly
recommend it and again you can even
repurpose it as a blog post so if it's a
podcast then you know you can recite
that podcast in the form of a blog okay
so get some testimonials
that support some of your content again
create a podcast you can send out an
email with a survey or trying to solicit
some testimonials or if you post
something on facebook you know leverage
the feedback you get from facebook in
the form of a testimonial okay and then
you want to promote your blog post for
maximum success and a lot of that means
seo so make sure you do your due
diligence and get the right keywords in
that blog post okay so you can create
personas for different user audiences
okay so remember it's all about tone
okay so if you're going to create a blog
post make sure your tone is aligned with
that right audience whether that be
young middle aged or older
are you choosing the right type of
content okay you'll know based on the
results okay you want to add h1 and h2
tags on your web pages why because when
we're talking about content we're
talking about organizing the content and
h1 and h2s help you organize the content
appropriately customize the metadata
metadatas title tag and meta tag
descriptions and even alt tags okay all
of that is for search so you want your
content to show up in search whether
that's video infographic or blog post
all of it can be shown in search results
so make sure you write a good title and
make sure you write a good meta
description because that's what people
are going to see when they search okay
so you want to create a detailed summary
and title and again that goes along with
the title tag and meta description and
then you want to make it easy for the
audience to ask questions and comment on
your blog so don't be afraid like i'm
going to do right now in this video is
if i'm missing anything from this
checklist feel free to comment hey i've
written my fair share content but i
could be talking to an audience that is
just as qualified as i am and they may
have some tips so feel free to comment
underneath this video now don't be
afraid to ask just like i just did
people are always willing to provide
constructive feedback so don't be afraid
to ask for it and make it easy so to me
every blog post needs to have some form
of a comment box because blog posts are
out there to solicit engagement now
let's recap everything we talked about
because we'd certainly covered a lot and
there's a lot to cover when it comes to
content marketing so one know your
audience again you can lean on google
analytics you know demographic data
whether it be age or gender you could do
the same with facebook and twitter and
linkedin you know every platform has
some data you could take away create
high quality content when i mean high
quality content brainstorm some topics
has it already been written to death
about or is this unique you know don't
write something your competitors are
writing okay don't copy what your
competitors have written organize your
content support it with good imagery all
of these are tips to creating high
quality content okay when you create
that content think about running to
maybe test you know run some variations
and switch out the image switch out the
call to action see what's going to get
people to react and engage with the
content conduct competitor analysis so
lean on the facebooks of the world to
see what your competitors are posting
see what's engaging for them okay you
can also lean on these seo platforms
like sem rush and moz all you got to do
is plug in a domain and they're going to
give you some information about where a
particular competitor ranks for keyword
or how many backlinks and what websites
are linking to them so all that's
available in these seo platforms okay so
you want to choose a suitable content
format we listed a few from ebooks to
case studies to podcasts to infographics
to blog posts to videos it's up to you
what you think is best for your audience
just keep in mind you need to be able to
measure it and so that's the important
thing if it doesn't work the first time
out then you might want to consider
changing out the content format choose a
content management system you know
plenty out there wordpress is a good one
if you're going to be a blogger okay
blogging allows you to
you know post optimize that blog post
you know you could have the ability to
share that blog post across social
platforms
and you can also have that blog post
show up in search engine results so you
can't do any of that without a good
content management system so you want to
target your audience using emails okay
so email is a good way to again further
communicate with that particular
segmented audience and again you could
use it to send out promotional emails to
loyal followers or
you can use systematic emails to send an
email a thank you email somebody
purchases and then another follow-up
email and again you can repurpose some
of the content you've done in another
format in the form of an email so
you know if you created a video you know
put that video in the form of an email
and send it out to your audience to make
sure they're not missing out on that
video you just created so lots of ways
to use email take advantage of email
it's your ally here okay use native ads
okay don't be afraid to put that content
and pair it with some other content on
another website it's been proven people
are going to engage in an ad that they
see based on the content they're
currently reading because the ad if it's
native it's going to be similar in
nature to the content they're currently
engaged in and then measure your content
performance i can't say this enough make
sure you're leveraging google analytics
okay with google analytics or facebook
insights or twitter or linkedin or any
other platform you're running on they're
gonna have data on what you've posted so
take advantage of it
align your kpis so if it's an e-book or
case study don't measure just traffic
measure how many people are actually
downloading them
in most organizations the people who are
doing search engine optimization have
been doing it for a while
and i can tell you because i've been
doing it for a while that in the old
days
it was mostly technical with a little
bit of content sprinkled in so for
arguments like let's say 80 20
80 percent of what an seo needed to
learn how to do
had to deal with you know you know your
meta tags your metadata you know uh cms
systems and a lot of blah blah blah
and oh by the way yeah you need some
content on the page
well here we are
a long time past that
and if this you you look through this
slide here for example
this is the latest guidance from google
on the kind of content they want
and if you look through the list here
most of the items on it aren't technical
and frankly most of it is content and if
you think about it
what this means is that the job
description for seo has changed
dramatically
particularly beginning with the panda
update but then including the
penguin update and then hummingbird and
pardon me
more and more and more seos had better
be interacting with the people who are
creating
quality content engaging content
credible content
useful content
it's not enough just to put keywords in
the right places anymore on pretty thin
content that won't get you where you
want to go
so again
different uh paths maybe the same
direction but the folks in content
marketing and the folks in seo
frankly need each other
and they may or may not recognize it in
your organization but you know it's a
starting point this is a conversation
you you probably need to have
content marketing is complex
it often overlaps with other elements of
marketing
uh the the most typical overlaps are
with social media marketing and seo
and uh there probably already are
in your organization those kind of
groups
the seos may be on
one floor and the social media marketing
people may be in a different building
you know whatever
but
the new success formula says we've got
to get all those folks to the same table
now we may have to do it virtually we
may have to use
you know webinars in order to hold those
kind of meetings who knows
but the point is is that uh you know the
world is shifting and organizational
structures need to shift with it
and again you know that's not something
you can change tomorrow
but that is something that will evolve
over time and
for what it's worth
it turns out that let's just say uh the
people who are in seo
they may or may not admit it at first
but they absolutely need to work with
the people in content marketing
why
because basically after panda and
penguin the rules shifted
and it's less about your title tag
and it's most mostly focused now on the
quality of your content
and whether that content is link worthy
which means it's really compelling
content it's remarkable content that's
content that's gonna get people to link
to it because wow that's
you know and that's not necessarily part
of the skill set that was required to be
a successful
seo five years ago or 10 years ago
so again you got to get these folks to
the table they've got to work together
you know and um
and again that means the organizational
structure probably needs to shift
and the same is true with the social
media marketing folks
you know
they went out and their initial
goals and objectives were
you know get lots of likes you know get
lots of fans
get lots of views get lots of twitter
followers why because that seemed to be
the metric that the platform gave us
and so we used it to measure success
well it turns out
none of those measures actually measure
real success
because they're focused on being
successful on the platform
boy i have lots of fans as opposed to
being successful in business
wow that generated lots of leads and
sales
so there is a real real discrepancy
between let's just say the center of
gravity
okay it's not facebook you're not going
to make
a lot of money on facebook
you know it's just not set up to do
business
you got to get those folks that you've
engaged in facebook
to your website where they can buy
something
and that's a you know radical shift for
all the folks who are in social media
marketing to say wait wait timeout
but that's not what i was told a couple
years ago and the answer is that's
correct what we've learned over time is
that being engaging is useful
if it's harnessed to
a benefit and i'll tell you in most
organizations the social media marketing
people are under cloud
because they aren't delivering
business benefit
and they too
need to learn to work with the content
marketing people
in order to do that and in some cases
they may not be creating the right kind
of content
that actually generates leads and sales
as opposed to
you know is inexpensive to create to get
my next fan or my next twitter follower
so the key metrics here are no longer
how many likes or comments or shares did
you get that's nice
but
how many sales leads did you generate
what percentage of those converted into
sales
that's a radical change
but again it helps when the
social media marketing people are at the
table with the content marketing people
greetings everyone this is rob sanders
from simply learn and today we're going
to talk about how to rank number one on
google high quality content and talk
about the impact content has on your
ability to get your website ranked
number one on google so let's just say
you have content on your website and the
content is ranking on
you know page four of google and it's
that blog with ice cream recipes and if
it's just content for the sake of
content is not really informative then
it's not necessarily gonna get good
engagement in the eyes of google you
know they want to rank content that's
very informative it's very fresh it's
exciting to read it's interesting it's
going to have good engagement so if it's
a recipe or an article about any topic
if it's the content is just not
informative then you're not going to get
good engagement and when you don't get
good engagement if people don't stay on
the site to engage in the content and
they just leave the website after
landing on the page causing a bounce
then the content is just going to
continue to fall down the rankings and
we want to prevent that we want to move
up the rankings we want to be number one
on google we don't necessarily want to
fall in the rankings for our content so
content is a key driver
in being able to rank number one on
google so if the content is on page nine
what can we do well we want to be able
to you know take that content and do
something with it we feel like we did
write engaging content so let's go ahead
and share it on social media and to me
social media is a good platform to share
your content because on social media
platforms like facebook for example
you're building a community on that
platform that community is already
interested in your content so if you're
sharing an ice cream recipe especially
in the summer time and you're engaging
with your community on that platform
then the likelihood of that community on
that platform is going to increase
engagement increased engagement will
send social signals to the search engine
that says hey this content is good
quality likewise for any other platform
most social media platforms have
engagement metrics and those engagement
metrics pass signals is it good is it
not good do we like this content are we
giving it a thumbs up are we going to
want to follow it are we going to want
to share it and so if you share content
that you feel is engaging on social
platforms then it's going to be engaging
and it's likely going to cause an
increase in engagement for example a
decrease in bounces and once you share
that quality content then the likelihood
of it moving up the rankings even as far
as number one on google is going to be
greater so you always want to start out
writing good quality content so let's
talk about good quality content because
google does take content seriously they
do take into account what other people
think of that content so high quality
content is an important factor so how to
create good content that's always the
question so let's talk about some best
practices here remember in the last
segment we talked about keyword research
so we want to perform good keyword
research why because we want to choose
keywords remember we're choosing
multiple keywords per page one keyword
could be related to our brand one
keyword could be related to the content
but another keyword could be related to
a user's intent like recipes if you
recall the example we use with bread
recipes maybe somebody's looking to type
in a keyword that says how do i make you
know a bread or how do i make a specific
type of bread or how do i make banana
bread or what's the best recipe for
banana bread they're question related
and we want to be able to answer those
questions so that's where choosing those
right keywords that's going to respond
to a user's intent so starts with
choosing the right keywords so remember
we talked about a number of different
tools when we talked about keyword
research so there's a research tool that
you can use called phrase.io and
that will help you do quick research on
you know keywords and trends and whatnot
so
if you know about a research tool that
you use for keyword research then drop
us a comment below i'd be interested in
getting your comments about keyword
research and what research tools are out
there so if you know something better
than phrase.io drop a comment below and
we'd be interested in getting your
perspective so keyword research is key
but creating content that fulfills users
requirements so answering those
questions it's a recipe we want to
answer that question if it's directions
we want to answer that question if they
don't know how to do something we want
to answer that question that's the whole
idea behind content content is not just
to fill a page it's to really fulfill
users requirements that's when you get
good engagement so if somebody's typing
in something on google and they're
looking for an answer your content
should answer that question but we also
want to make the content readable so in
other words you know write for your
audience don't impress anybody with
very high
vocabulary type words that somebody
doesn't necessarily know the meaning of
don't use jargon don't use a street
language for example use everyday common
language that's just easily digestible
when your audience is reading and then
we want to keep that content organized
and so when we mean organized we want to
use headers and subheaders you know
break your content into paragraphs keep
the flow organized if we can keep the
flow organized then it's going to be
easier for somebody to read and then
it's okay to add resources especially
resources from credible sites so if you
can incorporate those resources in there
then it's just going to add the
credibility to your content let the
audience know that hey i've done my
research on this topic and this is what
this person has to say about it this
person who seems to be credible okay so
it only adds value to your content so
these are all tips to remember when
creating content and then the one
important tip here is we want to use
white hat techniques and when we say
white hat techniques that means you know
if we've chosen keywords that are going
to answer somebody's question we don't
want to stuff those keywords into the
content we want the content to be
naturally written so when we say opt for
white hack uh techniques that's what we
mean write the content naturally keep it
organized keep it readable include
third-party sources and make sure it
answers a question so they're different
types of content so there's content
where you just write words to install
text based you could also use an
infographic an infographic is simply
just a graphic that visualizes exactly
what you're trying to explain for
example if we want to
write an article about
how to write good engaging content we
don't necessarily have to write all that
out as a text we can create an
infographic so for example here's an
infographic on 20 effective ways to
basically not bore your readers but
write engaging content so you could see
this is an infographic it's all
graphically laid out so infographics
tend to be easier to understand because
they're visual they're easy for the end
user to comprehend because there's
generally no jargon it's usually images
that are portraying the point of what
you're trying to get across and so it
tends to break it up the monotony of
just text it's more visually appealing
and it's laid out and organized so you
can see this infographic has 20
different steps or rules and they lay
those out all here in this infographic
and the great thing i like about
infographics is you could you could
share them on social media you can
re-engage them as a post you can save
them on really any social platform so
infographics tend to tell a better story
and versus say just writing text you can
use video and images so you don't
necessarily have to lay it all out in an
infographic you can certainly insert a
video or an image into
your content especially if it's a blog
post if it's a blog post then sometimes
video and images on its own
tell the story you don't necessarily
need text to
go ahead and tell your story a video or
an image as they say tells a thousand
words and so
images and videos are great to use in a
blog post so
using different forms of content you
know you always want to review your
content when a user dwells on your web
page for a longer time google will tend
to think okay this person's engaged so
we're going to rank that favor book so
if you're using
infographics videos and images then the
chances of somebody being more engaged
are going to increase versus just text
that's not well organized and written
out in a way that somebody doesn't
necessarily understand so be creative in
the types of content you use so longer
engaging content tends to bode well with
search engines so this is according to
hubspot so the more word count you use
the more words you use the chances of
you ranking higher are going to be
better just take into account best
practices you want to maybe break up the
content with an image organize it make
it engaging use headers so it's not
necessarily just words it's the words
and how those words are written how
they're structured the types of keywords
you're using how you're engaging with
your audience there's a lot of factors
again those best practices we just went
over but the key is you know if you have
longer more engaging content then it's
going to bode better for you on search
engines so a couple of steps to create
high quality content so you want to
begin with a comprehensive introduction
so always introduce your content
remember the content should be relevant
to the keywords so if you're choosing
keywords in your keyword research think
about answering that question if
somebody's typing in bread recipes maybe
they're looking for banana bread recipes
how to make the best banana bread or how
to make banana bread using dried figs we
want to be able to align our content
with that keyword naturally you want to
create a title that's worthy that's
click worthy so remember if you're in
google search and you're doing search
for something simple like bread recipes
we want to
make something that's going to be you
know engaging for somebody to click on
like easy perfect yeast bread or easy
crusty french bread or something that's
going to be engaging you know the best
bread recipes or how to make the best
homemade bread you know something that's
going to draw somebody's attention to
the title of that blog post so we want
to include lsi keywords so what i mean
by lsi keywords in your content we mean
you know long tail keywords make it
natural headings and subheadings should
consist of keywords and variants so
if you're writing headers and subheaders
include the keyword in there and that
way the the content always stays
relevant to the audience okay shorten
your sentences and paragraphs so don't
write long paragraphs remember we want
to break this up we want to make it easy
for the end user to read and we want to
always put internal links on our blog
post why because if we have internal
links then if we have a link from one
blog post to another blog post or say
our blog post to an internal page on our
website we want to make sure that it's
relevant content that way somebody's
reading something and you have an
internal link let's just say from a
bread recipes page to a banana bread
recipes page then they may find it
interesting click on that link and go to
the banana bread recipes page so it's
keeping somebody engaged on your website
so putting in internal linking will help
keep the end user engaged because you're
offering up links that's relevant to the
content you always want to break up that
content with images okay we want to use
alt tags meaning we want to
pen the image with text so that way if
the image doesn't load then at least the
alt text will load so we can incorporate
call out boxes and more importantly we
want to update our content regularly so
we always want to
get the best recipe out there if it's
banana bread or different ways to create
banana bread or always just coming up
with ways to update the content so we
want to keep our content our blog post
fresh and then we want to include a cta
call to action if we include a call to
action then that's going to keep
somebody engaged and have them act on
your content so these are
steps to creating high quality content
and so let's look at an example here and
this is a three-month-old post on
buzzfeed and it's 21 pictures that
restore your faith in humanity so it has
a lot of likes a lot of tweets and that
means it's engaged people are engaged
when reading that and so if we go and
look at it as an example we could see it
on a buzzfeed here 21 pictures that will
restore your faith in humanity so this
was written back in 2012 again a lot of
engagement but if we look at it we can
see immediately that it's taking into
account third-party sources it's got
some content it's got images it's being
broken up by images we can see there's
call to actions on there in the form of
social so people can go ahead and go
ahead and share it if they like it okay
it includes videos includes images
third-party sources so it's a good post
because listen you know it's engaging
content it's probably answering
somebody's question about humanity and
we could see clearly that look you know
there's a lot of different examples here
from a lot of different sources and we
could take action on this content so not
just video not just images but text as
well and so it's very engaging answers
questions takes into account the
different types of content available so
this is a good post in that regard so
content's updated regularly it's
engaging and it includes sources from
high authority websites some do's and
don'ts on the content so take into
account the best practices i mentioned
about creating high quality content okay
answer those questions that the end user
wants to hear you know because that
likely is going to be their search and
so you want to be able to respond to the
end user that's part of creating high
quality content different types of
content i.e in the form of infographics
or videos or text or images you can add
images from public domain sites you can
be relatable and use examples to clarify
points just like the buzzfeed article
simplify complex words don't use
sophisticated language talk to your
audience as if you they were standing
right in front of you and use bullet
points to exemplify your examples your
points so some do's the don'ts obviously
don't lift content we don't want to lift
content from another website so that's
plagiarism so we want to have our own
unique content we also don't want to
take images from other websites and so
if you do happen to find an image that
works for your post and it's on somebody
else's website ideally that's not a good
situation but if you do happen to do
that then always give credit to the
website okay so if you took it from
xyz.com credit xyz.com for the image and
even put a link back but ideally you
don't want to take images from other
websites just as much as you don't want
to take copy you don't want to take
images use your own imagery and content
but if you don't have imagery then you
can always go to stock photography there
are plenty of websites out there where
you can sign up for a subscription like
adobe stock images as an example you can
sign up for an account and in some cases
you can sign up for a free account and
use stock imagery okay don't give less
information to your audience give them
to your audience what they deserve which
is the information they're looking for
they're looking for the best banana
bread recipes give them the best banana
bread recipes incorporate your own
images break it up with titles give them
a good quality piece of content that
they're going to be able to engage with
and so if you put long paragraphs in
your content then it's going to be less
engaging so try to avoid those long
paragraphs remember shorten up the
paragraphs keep the language simple add
in images answer those questions use
third-party credible sources but write
it in your own words and you should be
on your way to creating good quality
content creating high quality videos and
some of the best practices around that
so along with everything we mentioned
about choosing the right keywords we
always need to keep in mind that the
videos we create need to be of high
quality so the content itself in
addition to the keywords this is a
primary factor in ranking so in order to
have keywords we need to have content
and in order to rank we need to have you
know good content so let's talk a little
bit about creating content and what's
involved with that and what we really
mean by high quality videos so if you
have a video content that is not
informative or relevant to the topic it
won't rank so that's just common sense
so you need to create content that's
aligned with the topic obviously and
then that way you have keywords that are
in line with the content so but if you
have content really isn't aligned with
the topic then you're not going to rank
no matter how much you've optimized that
video so just keep that in mind so
there's a couple of things we want to
look at here so high quality content is
determined by really two metrics so
we're not sure about how good our
content is and how good of high quality
video we created we want to look at
audience retention and user engagement
so audience retention is simply the
percentage length of your video that the
audience has watched it's the percentage
your audience has watched so focusing on
audience retention is important for
people who want their videos to rank
high so if you want to rank you need to
optimize for the keywords but got to
keep in mind content so content is
related to audience retention and user
engagement so audience retention
percentage length your video of your
video that the audience has watched and
for example it can be both absolute in
minutes or percentages so audience
retention can be the average view
duration or percentage of the audience
that watched then we have user
engagement so users are engaged from our
viewers who are engaged with your
content and so that means they're either
sharing it subscribing commenting or
liking so those are all forms of
engagement so the percentage of users
who watched or how long they watched
versus engagement or in combination with
engagement are two factors for ranking
so let's talk about some tips for
creating high quality videos so we want
to publish longer videos and so what do
we mean behind longer videos so what's
the reason for longer videos let's just
suppose we have two videos one shorter
in length and one longer in length first
video is 15 minutes long the second
video is seven minutes long so on
average if viewers watch about 40 of
both videos then video x which is 15
minutes long will have more than twice
the watch time of the video that's seven
minutes long so remember duration we
want you know people to watch our videos
longer so if the video is longer in
length if it's 40 then it's gonna have a
longer audience engagement audience
retention so that's one of the reasons
you know from a metric standpoint so
even when viewers watch you know both
videos the time is going to differ so we
want to take into account longer videos
for primarily that region is because you
know it gives an end user an opportunity
to
watch the video longer and then it's
going to help us rank our videos longer
so we talk about watch time so if one
video has
higher watch time than the other watch
time is just the number of views times
the average view duration so another tip
is we want to plan our video script so
we want to keep the content organized my
recommendation is you know create an
outline first and once you create an
outline of how the video is going to
flow then start populating with content
and so to me that's how you can keep the
flow organized okay is really with an
outline starting out with it on how
there's no videos are no different than
say a presentation if you've done a
powerpoint presentation you always want
to start out doing an outline then we
want to upload high resolution videos
high resolution we don't want to create
videos that you know are small
resolution like say you know 400 by 400
resolution or something you know
something really small we want to create
something a very high res so according
to back or link oaks more than 50 of
videos on the first page of youtube are
high definition so
high definition videos of higher quality
are going to be shown on the first page
of youtube more often than not so high
resolution videos organizing the content
publishing longer videos are examples of
creating high quality videos we also
want to make sure that content is
relevant to the title so if we're
talking about machine learning basics
you know obviously the content is going
to be about you know intro to machine
learning or what is machine learning and
then the title should reflect that
content so aligning the title sets the
expectation for the end user so when
they see a title what is machine
learning
then when they watch the video and
they're expecting to learn about machine
learning and what it is so if it meets
expectations then the chances are that
person who's watching the video is going
to watch it longer and that means it's
going to fulfill the viewers
requirements and when you align
everything accordingly keywords titles
content then at the end of the day view
users going to watch it and the more
they watch it the higher the engagement
the higher the engagement the better
chance you have to rank some other tips
that you could use to
create high quality videos so we want to
be able to you know use examples to
clarify our content so you know don't be
afraid to go into another screen like i
am if i want to i'm talking about videos
jump into the machine learning basics
video which i've done throughout this
session i can simply do that by keeping
the user engaged here this video is
about machine learning basics well the
title is online with the video we made
sure that we have a nice description
about what the video is about and we're
aligning the expectations so not only
that i'm showing you example within the
video itself so we want to use examples
throughout your video to keep the user
engaged it will also help clarify what
you're trying to express in the video
itself so we want to make it visually
appealing so visually appealing means
imagery or examples in the video and
then when we talk about imagery you know
you want to use good images in your
video so use public domain sites that
are available to you like shutterstock
or flat icon i mean there are plenty of
those sites out there so feel free to
use any one of those sites to
use high quality images in your video
give more information to your audience
giving maximum relevant information can
help gain more views and so when we talk
about more information again it goes
back to you know examples you use
there's no should be no shortage of
examples here description use all 5 000
characters at your disposal imagery we
want to build up as much information as
you can in the video itself to keep the
end user the viewer engaged we also want
to create original content so always
create original content you could
certainly get ideas from youtube if you
want to create a video about machine
learning see what else has already been
done do searches on youtube itself but
you know when you want to create a video
yeah you can create another video about
what is machine learning but just make
sure it has your own take on it you're
the subject matter expert when creating
the video create it with your own
original content have high audio quality
and video effects so just like you see
here on this video we have effects in it
and the audio is of high quality meaning
no background noise no distortion and we
want to be able to speak clearly in the
video so you want to speak clearly
loudly concise just as i'm trying to do
now so that you can understand what i'm
trying to say or what the viewers trying
to to understand when they're watching
the video so watching and listening are
two of the components and you want to
make sure both of our high quality avoid
distractions we don't want to pause you
don't want to ramble on a particular
point too long we want to keep users
engaged so you always want to move from
one point to the other intermix it with
examples those are ways to keep the
users engaged we want to include
transcripts or subtitles for your video
so transcripts is just more content
that's aligned with the video and the
search engines will be able to pick up
that content and help your video rank so
to me that's a key component to creating
a good video is having the necessary
content to go along with the video that
outline i referenced earlier in terms of
organization you always want to have a
content outline so what topics are you
going to cover in the video that's why
you need the outline to point that out
confirm that before you actually start
creating the video okay focus on the
initial 15 seconds so that's key you
know somebody's going to click the play
button of your video and if you don't
catch them in the first 15 seconds then
they're likely going to pause the video
or just go ahead and close it out all
together so you want to be able to
capture somebody's attention right off
the bat and even before they click on
that play button you want to make sure
again you're exceeding expectations that
title is aligned with the content so in
your first 15 seconds it basically needs
to be catchy but also setting the
expectation of what the user is
expecting so in this example here we
want to pay close attention to the first
15 seconds that's when viewers are most
likely to drop off so we can look at
audience retention in youtube so use the
options above the graph to view absolute
audience retention or relative audience
retention so audience retention is
basically how many views a video
received and the percentage of the total
number of video views and that includes
every moment of the video as a
percentage so we'll show you an example
of what that looks like so here if we go
to the machine learning basics video we
can look at the audience retention
report and this is since it's been
uploaded the lifetime audience retention
so here we can see a nice graph the
percentage of people who viewed it and
how long they viewed it so in percentage
so here for example i can see you know
43 44
watch the video for at least two minutes
here i can see 28.6
watch it for six minutes plus so that's
the audience retention it gives us an
idea in terms of percentage how many
people or percentage of people watch the
video at what length so that's audience
retention so we want to keep that number
high at the very initial stage of the
video and we want to keep it high
throughout and that's why you always
want to create high quality content
using those examples using imagery
making it organized content not pausing
you know going from one point to the
other those are all
best practices to keep the viewer
engaged and then we want to add
resources from well-known sites so
throughout this video we've used
backlinko there are other sources we've
used so if you have a source go ahead
and put it in your video to add
credibility and then we want to use
cards to your videos so this cards is
basically a feature that recommends
relevant videos to your audience so in
addition to machine learning basics
there could be other videos about
machine learning that we can recommend
or youtube can recommend to the audience
to set up end screens you want to make
sure that with end screens you can use
relevant videos to your audience towards
the end of your video so you can
recommend relevant videos towards the
end of your video you can also create
playlists so this is a feature that
keeps your audience engaged with
relevant content by autoplaying the next
video so if you enable this feature it's
going to go from one video to another
pattern interrupts keep the audience
engaged so basically
it allows your audience to stay within
one video without having any
interruptions involved and so going back
to the did you know audience retention
report helps you analyze how well your
videos are engaging to the audience so
what do we mean by that well i go back
again to my audience retention report
how engaging was it well i could see 42
percent 43
watched it on average of 3 minutes and
21 seconds so to me that's pretty good
of course we always want 100 of the
video the video is seven minutes long if
almost half of our audience saw over
half of the video then i would say
that's pretty good people were engaged
so audience retention just is a good
report to start looking at to help you
understand how engaging is my video and
if your video is not engaging you know
you can always go back and edit it or
fix it or tweak it so remember the
average view duration for all videos and
top performing videos listed by all time
we can look at that information as well
in addition we can look at demographics
so we can get an overview of the age
gender and location okay we can look at
playback locations report and what the
playback locations report does is it
helps us determine the platforms where
our videos are being streamed from
within youtube look at the traffic
sources where did the viewers come from
devices did they look on mobile or
tablet and so if there's any doubts you
know if you have any questions please
drop a comment below but especially if
you have any doubts on the metrics so if
we go back into youtube we can look at
analytics and if we're looking at
analytics we can see more and then this
is going to show us everything we need
to see from device type so if i click on
more i can see my playback location so
this will show me where the video was
watched it was on a watch page or a
channel page i could see the traffic
sources i could see the gender and age
so if i click on the viewer age report i
can see the percentage of views by age
so i can get a lot of information
about my video and how it's performed
who's watched it what they've done with
it where'd they come from all the
information they needed now okay so it's
all within youtube analytics so again if
you have any questions about that you
know just drop a comment below
especially if you're new to youtube you
may have some questions but just know
that every video you publish to youtube
high quality align with your keywords
you're going to be able to view the
metrics by looking at youtube analytics
now before we get into the tips and
tricks let's take a refresher on what
exactly is content marketing
content marketing is a form of marketing
that involves the creation and sharing
of online content to help generate
audience interest in a brand's product
or services this means providing
information that the audience considers
valuable and relevant in a consistent
manner so that it drives some sort of
profitable customer action
so let's talk about the content that
falls under content marketing there's
options like blogs
videos
infographics case studies white papers
and ebooks
so why is content marketing so important
firstly it helps build awareness trust
and loyalty in your brand
the more your brand provides accurate
and well-researched content the more
people learn about and trust your brand
the more the audience trusts in you the
more they're likely to buy from you
creating the content is relatively
inexpensive and can be done in-house
content marketing will also enable your
brand to increase traffic to your site
and get more conversions
it also helps improve other marketing
tactics like search engine optimization
social media and public relations
now let's have a look at the content
marketing process
the first step is to determine what
goals you want to achieve with your
marketing campaign it could be increased
conversions website signups and so on
then you set up buyer personas from
among your audience that can buy your
content but what exactly are buyer
personas
now these are research-based profiles
that represent your target customer
buyer personas help you describe your
brand's ideal audience
the decisions they make the challenges
they face their interests and so on
next you'll have to set up content
audits to determine the best type of
content that works for you
you also need to set up a content
management system like hubspot
squarespace wix and wordpress they'll
help you with increased collaboration
greater support run a b test and much
more
you need to brainstorm for new forms of
content that your audience can enjoy
after that you can zero in on a
particular form of content that would
work the best for you
and finally you can publish and manage
your content now let's talk about
content marketing tips
number one
re-market your content
content marketing is one of the many
ways you can spread your content to a
buyer audience you can define the
audience you want to market to and then
tag visitors who come to your site and
using google's display network you can
strategically position your ads in front
of people on google or its partner
websites who previously interacted with
your website and advertise to them
through this you can build awareness and
engagement with your audience
here's an example of a banner
advertisement i would be shown if i was
shopping for a macbook pro on amazon and
changed my mind at the last moment
this ad would maybe stay at the back of
my head until eventually i go and finish
that purchase
now let's go to number two answering
complex questions with your content
targeting specific keywords is extremely
helpful with your content this is why
you need to focus on google's featured
snippet this position also known as
position 0 enhances and draws user
attention on the search engine's result
page
through the featured snippet you can
drive a large amount of traffic to your
website while cementing your position as
an expert in your industry
you can have different forms of snippets
like definition boxes where a snippet of
text gives researchers direct and
concise definitions and descriptions
you could have tables where data is
taken from the page and displayed in a
table you could have ordered lists where
items are presented in specific order
and you can also have unordered lists
next up number three we have create a
personality for your brand
if you're looking to grow a following
for your content try not to copy how
already established and successful
corporate blogs do things
nowadays audiences tend to prefer
content that has a certain humanness
about it
tend to follow solo influencers they
advertise their brand by being
themselves
in a way they're selling themselves by
being themselves
you need to analyze what these popular
and influential blogs are doing and
incorporate into your brand's website
thanks to this your audience will
connect with you and come back for more
now here's an example of one of the
largest players in digital marketing
neil patel
see how he himself is the brand and if
you've gone through his content
you know it's pretty great as well
that's what you should be striving for
moving on to tip number four
ensure that your content matches your
brand's voice
to make sure of this you need to
constantly review your editorial
standards and make sure your tone and
quality remain consistent
you need to ask your audience questions
about how you can develop and refine
your brand's voice
by answering these questions you can
provide your audience with a more
cohesive and helpful experience
your tone of your brand can vary on the
basis of what type of content you're
planning to post and what the goal you
want to achieve from the campaign
next up we have number five
back up your arguments for data
using statistics and facts to make a
point by including a link to the
original source makes it extremely
credible this data can help the audience
grow trust in your brand to persuade
them that your content is valid and
valuable this will also help your brand
grow as an industry expert
at number six
we have use specific keywords
now make sure you use specific keywords
in your content this takes care of the
seo aspect behind your content
this will also help your content have a
greater chance of being found indexed
and ranked
it could also help your content rank for
niche topics within your industry moving
on to tip number seven
evaluate the success of your content
with data
earlier we talked about why it's so
important that you back up your content
with data
now let's talk about how data can help
you improve
analytics tools will help you learn more
about how well your content is doing the
age demographics of the people enjoying
it who doesn't their locations the best
time to post and much more
with this data you can make sure that
your time and money are being used in
the best possible way
some of the most popular tools in the
market are buzzsumo evernote hubspot
trello and wordpress
these will help you find topics and
influencers within your industry you can
capture organize and share notes
collaborate with team members create
sales funnels and much more
now we've reached midway right now so
i've got a question for you
do you guys have any tips for content
marketing that we haven't covered yet
let me know in the live chat
alright so let's get back to our list
tip number eight is to be consistent
with your content
post your best performing content and
make sure they follow a consistent
schedule
finding a balance of the different types
of content to be posted with the help of
a content calendar will show your
audience that you're committed to
providing them helpful and informative
content this will also establish your
brand as an authority and thought leader
within your niche it will help your
audience depend on you for quality
content and give them a reason to return
tip number nine is to make your content
actionable
providing actionable steps or
information in your content will coerce
your audience to take a particular
action quickly
it can help you create valuable content
and fix pain points faced by your
audience build a strong relationship
with them and earn their trust
it also leads to increased engagement
and a positive brand experience
it provides users with real value and
solutions leading them to take action
here we have an example from trello
where we see a pop-up with a call to
action asking interested users to input
their email ids to sign media today
involving more than 200 marketers more
than 49 percent of them felt content
marketing was really important to their
digital marketing campaigns and more
than 25 percent of their budgets are
used for visual advertising content like
images infographics
videos and other forms of rich media
will help you enhance the message of
your brand and reach a wider audience
here's an example of advertising by
coca-cola
although there's not a lot of text in
the ads you can immediately recognize
the unmistakable branding and the
message they're trying to send moving on
to tip number 11
create trending and evergreen content
creating content that's evergreen and
trending with your own unique angle
statistics and research will be a huge
advantage since you'll have to update it
every now and then you'll get a great
deal out of the work without having to
do a lot of work here's an example of
one such evergreen article
people are never going to stop wanting
to learn how to do seo so with a little
tweaking every few months to reflect new
changes that google may have done you'll
have an article that you can get
considerable mileage out of
next up tip number 12 is to understand
content that works for you
you need to analyze what content works
on different social media platforms
for example you all know youtube is the
best place for video content
instagram and pinterest for visual
content twitter for smaller snappy
content and so on
understanding what works and what
doesn't will help you better spread your
content across the internet
tip number 13 is to understand your
target audience
now like i mentioned earlier your
marketing campaign isn't going to bear
fruit without targeting a specific
audience
understanding who your audience is is
one of the most important steps for this
you can find us out by asking questions
like who you're engaging with online
their age location language etc
by using social listening to find out
what audiences are talking about your
brand using tools to research what
social channels your audience is using
and so on
after understanding them you can set up
buyer personas for your audience
tip number 14 is to perform a b testing
now abs testing will help you understand
what your audience likes or doesn't what
content works for you and much more
you can do a b testing on headlines and
title tags call to actions content
formats image types content length and
much more it can also help you make
better decisions in the future
and finally our tip number 15 is to
reach out to people sharing similar
content
one of the best ways to build your
audience is to get people or influencers
who already share content within your
niche to share your content
now since these people already have a
trusting audience they would be a lot
more likely to enjoy your content
content marketing interview questions
and answers so thanks for joining again
and here's how it's gonna work so if you
have any questions to these questions or
answers feel free to just comment right
below this video and we'll get back to
you as soon as possible we're going to
go through a series of questions and i'm
going to answer those questions for you
starting out what are the essential
components of a good web content okay so
essential components okay so what do we
want our content to do well we want it
to be useful so web content should be
written in a way which caters to what
the reader wants okay so somebody's not
going to read your content if it's not
useful for them okay this because it
affects reader engagement okay so if
it's not interesting it's not useful
somebody's just not going to read it
plain and simple it also has to be
engaging so listen even if it is
relevant to a user you still have to
write the content so it's engaging so
you want to add elements like imagery
videos hey you can even turn your
content into an infographic okay you
want to do something that's going to be
engaging for the user if it's engaging
they're going to read it and engage with
the content okay and then good content
should have some call to action so
content must be written in a way that
can drive call to action okay so if
you're writing a blog post you know i've
seen a lot of blog posts just simply
start and with good content but it
doesn't leave the user with anywhere to
go so have that call to action put some
internal links in that content give
somebody a place to go after done
engaging with the good content that you
write okay so some other things to think
about some other components for good
content well credibility so you know
anybody can write but are you writing
about something you know what you're
writing about are you a good talking
point a good expert or have experience
about this content so you also want to
use you know information from a
legitimate source okay so you don't want
to grab something in your and use it in
your content that's just not legitimate
because it does hurt your credibility
and the organization's credibility and
then also originality i mean write
something
that nobody else has written so
obviously you don't want to plagiarize
because if you plagiarize and there are
tools out there where people can easily
just put their content in there to see
what else is out there see if somebody
else has plagiarized it so it's very
easy to find people who plagiarize so
don't be that person what i would
recommend create a good content calendar
and come up with some ideas before you
write them next question related to
content marketing so what are the types
of content you can create well there are
a lot of things you can create start
with the blog blog to me is always a
great place to start it's a blank canvas
for your ideas your thoughts your
opinions okay that's a great thing about
a blog it accentuates personality you
can create a video videos are always
engaging you can create an infographic
infographics to me are you know hidden
gem instead of somebody reading the same
old same old you're laying this out in a
very visual way that's easy to
understand create a case study okay so
if you're a digital marketing expert
you've done social media for another
client you know write about it you know
show the successes show that you are an
expert show that you've created
successful campaigns and social and in
the form of case study you can create a
white paper white papers are good
educational pieces you can also create
an ebook okay ebook hey if you have a
lot of content you want to lay it out
and ebook's a good way to go and you
have a lot of choices here when it comes
to content a lot of choices okay so what
are the advantages of having a content
counter so i alluded to that just a
couple of seconds ago so let's really
break this down here because content
calendars to me are so important well
first of all calendar part of content
calendar allows you to think about dates
so if you're planning something you're
gonna have important dates in mind okay
so content calendar it almost ensures
you don't miss anything you know that's
a good opportunity for you to leverage
like you know black friday cyber monday
you know it's probably important you
know when those days are if you're in
e-commerce so that's why having a
content calendar helps it helps you plan
out your content based on important
dates or based on dates that work for
what you're trying to do they also help
because you could stick to a consistent
schedule okay so if you don't have a
content calendar you're probably just
arbitrarily writing content here and
there well what if your users crave and
really engage with the content they're
going to want more sticking to something
consistent is going to really get people
to come back for more they know when
you're going to post they're going to be
waiting for it and if it's every tuesday
morning 8 o'clock hey post it tuesday
morning eight o'clock your users will
get used to that schedule and it does
help build up your following it does
help to help build up your community and
in the end cultivates a long-lasting
relationship and then having a content
calendar also allows you to mix up your
content okay so you can see and plan
ahead different types of content in
different formats that way it allows you
to mix it up whether it be a blog post
uh an infographic a video about
different topics okay some other
advantages here saving time it just
allows you to prepare for the future
when you can prepare you're efficient
and when you're efficient you're not
wasting time and so to me having a
content calendar is a must because a lot
of us are busy who has time especially
if you're going to work in a new company
let's say writing content you definitely
want to have a content counter because
you're going to want to use that time to
efficiently plan this is a new company
you're going to start working at you
want to understand who this company is
what they've done in the past what you
haven't done and what you want to do
okay so all of that helps you plan and
prepare and it saves you the time and
effort and hassle down the road and then
at the end of the day you want to be
able to figure out what works so
planning your post puts less strain on
you and your team members as well as
company resources because when you plan
and you post you're going to get data
and then when you get data it's either
going to work or not work and if it
doesn't work then you know in the future
you're not going to put that piece of
content or the topic in the content
calendar again it's that simple okay
some other advantages fresh content okay
so having a con content calendar allows
you to always keep content fresh ken
you're going to be on a consistent
schedule and you're not going to be
writing about the same things over and
over again so it could be just simply
twitter if you're putting a content
calendar and it together for twitter
well you don't want to have the same
tweets every other day so it does ensure
that you're getting tweets out there
that are fresh that are new that are
different and again figure out what
works a content counter makes it easier
to measure results and optimize
performance so you always want to you
know maybe put some metrics in with your
content calendar so you can see side by
side content historically that is
performed content that is not performed
okay so next question you may get what
type of content works in each stage of
the customer life cycle so you have
awareness engagement purchase post
purchase advocacy okay so let's break
these down here so awareness okay so you
want people to understand who you are
okay that could be a guest blog an
influencer helping you out it could be a
cold email a v a video that can
potentially go viral a social media post
introducing a product you have
engagement so you want people to engage
with your content what are you going to
do to get people to engage well you
could certainly write an email and have
people open that email and go to your
website you can have an ebook where
people can actually download and read it
or you can have a blog where people can
comment or landing page where they can
fill out a form submission you have
evaluation so with social media we know
there's a lot of engagement going on but
when you're putting content out there
you can certainly open it up to
testimonials okay you can generate white
papers okay or you can generate case
studies case studies a good way for
companies to evaluate what you've done
in the past if you've worked in it for a
specific product in the past and it's
worked you certainly want to put that
out there for potential clients in that
same industry purchase trying to get
people to purchase what are you going to
do well you can certainly have landing
pages a nice you know website a nice
shopping cart with some nice content
okay onboarding emails get those emails
out there and get people to go back to
the website and purchase of course you
can have product and service details as
well meaning you know one one page
downloadable pdfs that describe the
product okay a post purchase okay so
people who've already purchased you can
certainly send out follow-up emails and
you can do blog roundups you know give
people an opportunity to see what
features or updates are happening to the
product okay of course case studies of
repeat customers or content types that
detail a new feature or service okay so
if somebody's already purchased hey you
may want to send them some content of
another product that complements the
product they bought so a lot of things
you can do to engage with your user
who's already purchased and then
advocacy you want people to help you out
here so have the user generate the
content you can have exclusive discounts
for your community they're gonna be your
advocates so give them exclusive
discounts and then pictures of customers
engaging with your products okay who's
not gonna share that so you're gonna
have people share that information in
other words you can generate content
where hey people can help you out here
and be your advocate okay so how do you
decide what topic and subject to write
on okay well going back to the content
counter that always helps you see what
you put in that content calendar but
there are some other methods you can use
and you could certainly identify your
target audience and not only identify
your target audience but what their
needs are okay so you can write content
based on audience you could certainly do
some research with keywords okay what's
trending what keywords are not trending
okay and right around what's trending
for example okay you could certainly
take a look at social media for example
korra i always look at korra core is
interesting entertaining informational
people are certainly having
conversations on core and you can
certainly analyze those conversations
because they certainly get in depth and
you can decide hey do i want to write a
topic around something that really just
won't go away in terms of conversing
core is a good example of analyzing
conversations they tend to be a little
bit more in-depth so some other things
you could do you can look at your
competitors and what kind of
conversations are happening on your
competitors blogs or or your competitors
social media platforms and pages you can
keep track of blogs and articles from
subject matter experts commentators
critics and so on okay so you can get
ideas from them another question you may
get which is very important if you're
going to start working for a company you
need to understand the tone the tone of
your content because that is going to
fit and be in line with the company
you're working for okay so you're always
going to have a brand personality so the
characteristics of a brand are the
guidelines based on which the content
strategy is developed the tone of the
content must align itself to the content
strategy your audience profile so you
got you need to determine who your
audience is okay and how the brand wants
to be seen by that audience so you know
if you have an older audience you're not
going to use younger audience i.e street
lingo or today's lingo and and the
younger generation uh you're going to
use you know language that's going to
fit the audience you're talking to and
then of course the channel itself so the
content you create must be irrespective
of the channel consistent with brand
attributes okay so you gotta pick and
choose the channel if it's linkedin for
example hey you know linkedin's more
business oriented okay so you're not
gonna be
you know as humorous as you would be say
on instagram or facebook all of these
have one thing in common again that's
brand guidelines you have to stay within
the brand what is the brand's
personality how do we want to talk to
our audience and what platform are we
using to talk to our audience how do you
promote your content once it's live well
that's always a good question hey you
doing the the work the putting in the
hard work to create this you know it
could be a video and videos take a long
time it could be an infographic an ebook
okay so send it out via email okay if
you have an email list send it out and
let people know this content's there put
a link in the email or or even a piece
or snippet or preview of the content in
the email so you're using the email to
broadcast and encourage people to you
know if it's an ebook get the rest of
the ebook okay you could certainly
leverage social media to engage with
your community that's the best you know
just as good as email get out there and
let people know hey i got i got my book
published come and download it you know
you can give a discount to the first 100
people that download it okay you can
always promote your content via ads so
whether that be google or facebook you
always have an opportunity to meet more
prominent by advertising the content
that you have to offer so you can always
reach out on social media again
targeting interesting people directly so
you can always interact with people on
social or you can write for others
attract people from the web to important
pages of your website by guest posting
so you can always go on to a popular
blog post and write something and you
know link it up or or have it be
relevant to the content you've written
so next question how can you determine
how well your content is doing okay very
important again you've done all the work
you've put the content calendar together
you got the content ready to go it's
published you're promoting it social
email guest blogging but you want to
determine how it's doing well depends on
the channel really is what it comes down
to so if it's organic search you want to
be able to see if it's ranking for the
keywords you optimize that content for
if it's social you want to be able to
see if you have engagement shares
comments etc of course you can always
look at analytics and see how much
traffic that blog post is getting or
that page with the white paper is
getting okay so you can always look at
your analytics and look at the traffic
okay and again you can always look to
see if there are conversions in the form
of an inquiry or lead or sale so at the
end of the day you want to align the
content with the channel and you want to
align the kpi with the content and
channel okay so if it's social you're
not likely going to get conversions
unless you're doing paid ads if you're
posting organically on social then
you're probably going to get some
engagement so you have to align the
right metric with the right channel what
are the steps involved in the content
marketing process okay so you really
need to decide what goal you want to
achieve with the content marketing
campaign so that goes back to what i was
just saying a minute ago if you have
content you post it on social then
what's the goal what are you trying to
achieve well you're probably going to
get engagement and likes
you need to define buyer personas to
determine the audience best suited for
your content okay so you're always
writing for an audience and you're going
to market that content for that audience
so you always got to keep that in mind
okay run content audits audits to
determine the best type of content that
can be used in other words how did it
perform what kind of engagement did you
get with the infographic or did that
video really really perform well or do
we want to use you know a blog post next
time around or an image next time around
so continuing on here you want to choose
an appropriate content management system
okay so how are we managing all this
content okay is it wordpress or is it
another platform okay you could start
brainstorming for ideas for new content
so again that goes back to the content
calendar you leverage your content
counter to always create ideas for new
content okay then you want to settle on
a particular type of content that you
want to create okay so once you come up
and you're managing your content you you
come up with some ideas then you
obviously want to
choose the format and then of course you
want to publish and manage your content
after it's all said and done so these
are the steps involved again just
quickly decide on the goal the kpi
deciding your audience look at what's
worked and not worked in the past get
your content set up in the platform okay
or get the platform ready to go i should
say okay generate ideas with that
content counter i ideally go to the
content calendar for the ideas choose
that type and then publish and manage
and when i say manage i mean again going
back to analytics or going back to the
kpi that you align with that content to
see if it's performing or not okay so
next question here how do you target the
right audience for your content it's a
very good question you're not writing
content for everyone let's be honest
here so you have to collect demographics
of your target audience based on who's
coming to your website based on who
subscribed to your emails based on who's
following you on social media so in
other words you have people interacting
with you okay in different channels and
you need to understand who these people
are so if they fit a certain age range
your generation are they skewed more
female to male education level what's
their affinity or interest okay do they
have a certain income so you need to
really break down your audience here and
you could do that in analytics you could
do that on social you can do that just
by looking at your email list okay the
all those will paint a picture as to who
your audience is i'm greg jarbo i'm a
member of the market motive faculty in
this first section we're going to talk
about what content marketing is how it
works
and also explore why it works
it seems like a new buzzword to you it's
actually a term that's been around for
quite some time
it's just web search interest in content
marketing has tripled since 2010
according to google trends and that's
why a lot of people are now just
starting to get their arms around it
so what is content marketing
well according to rebecca lee a friend
of mine who wrote an article in
advertising age
content marketing is not just a
glorified way to say social media
marketing it's actually a little broader
concept so content marketing does
include social media and you can use
blogs facebook twitter youtube vimeo
linkedin google plus pinterest
foursquare instagram flickr stumbleupon
tumblr slideshare and quora and you can
put all of those together
in a content marketing program
and all of this content
can be optimized so it can be found in
search engines
as well as in social media
or in the usual places like your website
one of the ways to sort of conceptualize
this is the classic venn diagram
brian clark of copyblogger has put
together a really interesting white
paper called the business case for agile
content marketing
in which she's created this particular
diagram that shows
search social and content and the
overlap of the three
is where he positions content marketing
and that may help you understand where
it fits it's sort of a little bit of
this a little bit of that but it also
shows you both the potential leverage
that you can get when you begin
combining these elements but also the
potential conflicts you may encounter
inside an organization who says hey wait
a second that's my job and the real
challenge to content marketing
is getting people who have been doing
their job independently headed off in
their own unique direction
to actually collaborate and coordinate
what they're doing
and leveraging each other's capabilities
to create something that's a little more
powerful
in the world of digital marketing you
must have heard the term copywriting
but very few people talk about
copywriting it's one of the essential
skills for any digital marketer it has
been estimated that there are 1 lakh 31
200 copywriters in the united states
today
it is projected that the copywriting job
market will grow by 7.6 percent from
2016 to 2026.
freelance market for copywriting is on
our role companies like upwork and fiber
are filled with copywriters there are
many advantages of freelance copywriting
jobs like being your own boss a flexible
schedule and doing what you love what is
copywriting in simple words copywriting
is a type of writing or a set of words
that will convince the reader to take
some kind of action
and that action can be anything like
registering for an event signing up for
something or buying a product
businesses usually hire copywriters to
write landing pages facebook and google
ads copy social media posts etc in order
to convince the readers to take some
action copywriting should be part of any
marketing plan and is one of the most
powerful ways to capture the attention
of your target audience and motivate
them to convert or purchase copywriting
is everywhere when you go online or even
offline remember the google ad that you
see when you search for something in
google that is a copy or if you check
your email box you will find different
promotional mails by different companies
that are a copy
basically those companies are trying to
convince you to take some action it can
be anything for example an e-commerce
company will convince you to purchase
some of their stored products
now let's talk about the copywriting
formula a good copy usually follows aida
formula a stands for attention i for
interest d for desire and a for action
almost every good copywriter uses this
formula to write better copies and it's
important for you in case you decided to
become a copywriter or want to use
copywriting in some of your work so i
hope now we understand what actually
copywriting is now let's try to
understand what does a copywriter
actually do
the copywriter's job is to write words
that convince an audience to take some
action for the benefit of the company in
which the writer works
let's have a look at sample copyrighted
job description that will help you
understand the role and responsibilities
and the skills needed for this role
so firstly let's have a look at
responsibilities writing editing and
publishing engaging content for various
social media network including facebook
twitter instagram linkedin and google my
business optimizing social media post
language tone message based on your
target audience behavior selecting
appealing images and videos to
complement text for designers to design
the post
let's have a look at some more
responsibilities coordinate with
internal teams to create advertising
posts for client respond to questions
and comments on social media pages
promptly and accurately
there can be more responsibilities to a
copywriter depending on what the company
needs so it varies from company to
company now let's see what skills a
company looks for in a copywriter
hands-on experience using various social
media platform to advertise solid
knowledge of seo keyword research and
analytics tools example google analytics
familiarity with online paid advertising
let's have a look of some others
requirement and skills
ability to deliver creative web content
text image and video excellent
communication skills
so now we know what copywriter does
let's explore its various types
seo copywriting it means optimizing the
copy using keywords to make it rank at
the top of the search results for
example if you optimize a company's
product page correctly through seo
copywriting then there is a high chances
that your sales page would rank at the
top of the search result which would
result in more sales next we have social
media copywriting this type of
copywriting is used on social media
platform for example a catchy title is
used to grab the attention of the user
and emoji is used to make the copy
interesting or frame the right message
in order to convince the audience to
take some kind of action next we have
technical copywriting the motive for
writing technical copy is to explain the
latest technologies or the technical
product that a company wants to sell for
example if you have a tech product you
need a copywriter who can explain the
technical aspect use case of the product
and how that product helped the customer
direct response copywriting it is a type
of communication that is compelling
enough to be able to influence the
customers to act
in other words any copy that encourages
the recipient to act immediately and the
response from the reader are miserable
another type of copywriting is public
relation copywriting in public relation
copywriting you write newsworthy things
to catch your audience attention and
gain their trust it helps you quickly
earn an audience with credible sources
and as a result your business can
promote its product and services more
effectively whenever you search on
google you see some ads at the top of
the search results that are also made up
using copywriting following that next we
have ad copywriting this type of
copywriting is used to create effective
ads generally it's used in facebook and
google ads now we reached the second
last type of copywriting in the list
which is email copywriting as you
understood by the name all the copy that
we use in emails are email copywriting
it includes a good subject line nice
preview text an intro sentence for the
body of your email and a strong call to
action
now let's discuss our last type which is
brand copywriting brand recognition and
connecting with customer begin with
communicating what your brand represents
your brand image can be conveyed through
writing it can be in the form of logo a
song or a phrase to create brand copy
you have to think about your customers
first with this we have come to the end
of this copywriting types list before
jumping into the next topic i have a
task for you just pause this video and
in the comment box type your favorite
type of copywriting i hope you are done
with the comment
let's move forward to our next topic
which is difference between copywriting
and content writing
firstly let's discuss the difference
based on the overall goal
copywriting is a type of writing aimed
at selling a brand on the other hand
content writing is all about building a
perception in consumer's mind the next
difference is based on the length of the
content a copywriter typically writes
short form of copy and a content writer
writes long form of copy text written by
copywriter is brief and engaging content
writer often have to write more in-depth
content explaining a process or topic
now what's the difference when it comes
to a role in a company a copywriter is
someone whose primary role is to create
copy and a content writer often does
more than just write it may be a writer
blogger executive or anyone else
lastly let's discuss the difference
based on seo a good copywriter
understand seo but when it comes to a
good content writer they should know
about the advanced seo
now let's explore some of the helpful
tools for a copywriter copy ai it's an
ai tool and the greatest thing about
this tool is it's very simple to use you
can generate instagram caption product
description and even product value
proposition by just providing a few
words it's a paid tool but it has a 7
days free trial the next tool that we
have is grammarly grammarly is a free
online tool that finds mistakes in your
writing and suggests improvements as you
write grammarly will underline any
mistake you have made and offer
suggestions on how to fix them
additionally it has a plagiarism checker
and a punctuation checker however for
additional features you need to go with
grammarly premium
what tune with the help of grammarly you
can fix your writing mistakes but when
it comes to rephrase and rewording your
content without sacrificing flow tone or
meaning word tune came into the picture
hence the combination of grammarly and
word tune is the best for the copywriter
and it's a paid tool but have a free
plan for beginners
the last tool in our bucket is wordsmith
if you rely on data in your day to day
decisions wordsmith is a perfect for you
it can be used for everything from
journalism to financial reporting
because it produces natural sounding
content simply create one template and
set up a few variables and worst myth
will generate multiple alternative
scripts for example you can write
chatbot scripts for responding to
various complex customer requests
now comes the most interesting and the
last topic of a session the average
salary of a copywriter several factors
determine the income a person can expect
including experience the size of your
company your location and your industry
copywriters are the brain behind
advertisements explaining what the
product does and why people should buy
it they are also responsible for shaping
the brand's identity and tone of voice
copywriters are a valuable resources for
businesses as they are responsible for
writing the first impression customers
get of a company a copywriter earns
approximately 3 lakh 64 000 per annum in
india and in the us he she can earn
roughly 53 000
and when it comes to a senior copywriter
the average salary in india is 5 flag 86
000 per annum and in the u.s he she can
roughly earn 78 000
per year
so with this we have come to the end of
the session on copywriting i hope the
session was informative and exciting in
case you have questions about any of the
topics covered in the session or if you
need resources used in this session then
please feel free to let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
practitioners will be more than happy to
resolve all your queries at the earliest
until next time this is tushar from the
simply learn team
signing off thank you stay safe and keep
learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here
you